[Zene]
Üdvözlök minden egyes kedves hallgatót
és nézőt. A mai beszélgetés különösen
izgalmasnak fog ígérkezni. Nagyon régóta
foglalkoztat engem a a halál és a
szenvedés kérdése, és igazából erről nem
nagyon szerettünk beszélgetni erről a
kérdésről.
A következő két
vendégem, Zoltáni Kinga és és Balázs
Anna, két olyan hölgy, akik daganatos
betegségben szenvedtek
és és mondhatjuk, hogy túlélők. Ez ez
egy helyes kifejező kifejezés. Igen,
igen, igen. Már lehet így használni.
Úgyhogy a legkeményebb kérdésekről
szeretnék veletek beszélgetni, de
mindenesetre köszöntelek titeket a
stúdióban, köszönöm, hogy elfogadtátok
ezt a meghívást. Én is köszönjük. Ez egy
az az igazság, hogy én sokat
gondolkoztam azon, hogy főleg
családapént, hogy mi fog mi történne
akkor, ha most hirtelen kiderülne, hogy
hogy tegyük fel agydaganaton van, ami
nem egy irreális dolog, mert mert
nagyatám agydaganatban hunyt el sajnos.
És
emlékszem, amikor vagy körülbelül olyan
10 évvel ezelőtt elkezdett sípolni az
egyik fülem, és rákerestem, hogy a
fülsípolásnak milyen
milyen okai lehetnek, akkor az egyik ott
volt valahol azért, hogy ne ijesszem meg
a harmadik oldalnak az alján egy ilyen
kicsi bekezdésben, hogy esetleg lehet
agydaganatnak a következménye, akkor
nagyon megijedtem.
pánik ez ilyen pánikot pánik rohamszerű
érzés volt, és el is mentem ilyen
MRI-ra, hogy megvizsgálják, és és nem
kaptak semmit. Utána aztán megnyugodtam.
Amúgy a fülem most is sípol ebben a
pillanatban is egy kicsit, de attól
függetlenül nagyon sokat foglalkoztat ez
a foglalkoztatott ez a kérdés, hogy
hogy mi lenne, ha kiderülne, mi lenne az
életemmel, mi fog mi változna, mert
annyi mindent csinálok, annyi minden
függ attól, hogy én egészséges legyek
ebben a pillanatban, hogyha most
kiderülne a prioritásaim valószínűleg
tetejére állnának, és vajon mi lenne a
családommal.
Úgyhogy kezdem egy könnyű
kérdéssel igazából bele a sűrűjébe.
Kicsit mesélnétek attól arról a
pillanatról, amikor számotokra is hát ez
az üstökös beütött az életetekbe, hogy
milyen volt, amikor amikor először
megtudtátok, hogyan tudtátok meg, hogy
hogy daganatos betegek vagytok?
Én ahogy édesanyám beteg lett, neki mell
daganata volt, és felhív felhívták a
figyelmünket, hogy hogyha lányok,
ahányan vagyunk a családban, hogy
mindnyájan
járjunk
szűrővizsgálatokra. És én 2013-tól
kötelezően mentem is szűrővizsgálatra.
Nem, nem vették észre, hogy daganat van,
amit én aztán 2016 decemberében
tapintottam egy daganatot, egy csomót a
ellenembe, és akkor akkor indultam el,
hogy hogy ez akkor valami nincs rendben.
Úgyhogy én így így kezdtem a Tehát volt
egy folyamata, készültél, figyeltél már
erre figyeltem és és tudatosan és minden
évbe mentem kontrollra. És amikor kijött
a diagnózis, hogy hogy gondolom, hogy
volt egy pár hét, ameddig megvizsgálták
és húzódott az idő, és ott a levegőben.
Jó pár hónap. Igen, jó pár hónap. Jó pár
hónap. Tehát, hogy ez ez nagyon
elhúzódik ez az időszak általában és ez
a ez nagyon nagyon megviseli a a
betegeket. Ühüm. Tehát, hogy ez talán ez
a legszörnyűbb időszak, merthogy
várakozik az ember, nem tudja, hogy mit
kell tenni, nem tudja, hogy hova
induljon el. Nagyon nehéz ez az ideg
idegtépő időszak
ez. Hm. Mertogy hogy már hogyha az ember
tudja a diagnózist, akkor már kapja,
hogy hogy mit. Igen. És akkor az ember
kezdi tenni a dolgát. Kezdi tenni a
dolgát. És attól a ponttól, akkor már
hogy hogy érzi az ember, hogy na akkor
ezt teszem magamért, tehát hogy
felelősséget válok, vállalok, döntéseket
hozok a hogy egészséges legyek. Anna, ez
a te esetedben hogy volt? Hát nem volt
derültékből villámcsapás, mert szintén
2016, csak hogy én ez év tavaszán
tapintottam egy nagyon-nagyon pici
csomót a menemben, tehát a pánik az ott
jelent meg. Ez év tavaszal, tehát
2016-ban volt itt egy elhúzódás, amiben
sajnos nekem volt egy kicsi részem. Most
nem mondom, hogy hanyagság, hanem azt
mondom, hogy életkörülvények. Üüm, tehát
a pánika az az volt, hogy picike a
csomó. El is rohantam, megnéztük, akkor
tényleg azt mondta a doktornő, hogy hát
ő mindenképp szeretné ezt követni két
hónap múlva meg fogjuk ismét nézni.
Csak, hogy itt történtek dolgok, tehát
olyan változások voltak a
magánéletemben, ami miatt én hát szó
szerint háttérbe szorítottam ezt a
dolgot, tehát nem foglalkoztam vele.
Nem, nem mondom azt, hogy megfeledkeztem
róla, de egyáltalán nem fog nem volt
prioritás.
És
decemberben volt az a pont, amikor
éreztem, hogy jelentősen megnövekedett a
csomó. Tehát akkor már küldte is a
jeleket, hogy itt vagyok s foglalkozzál
velem. Tehát nyilvalt
diszkomfortérzésem volt, és még mindig
volt bennem egy eltolás,
mert annyira ingoványos talajon álltam
én még akkor, hogy tényleg azt éreztem,
hogyha most valaki nekem a szememben
mondja, hogy rákos vagyok, én nem tudom
ezt elviselni.
Úgyhogy itt áttoltam az egészet a
következő év elejére, amikor aztán egy
reggel úgy ébredtem, hogy hát most olyan
erős vagyok, hogy most megyünk a dolog
elébe.
Nagyon-nagyon hamar kiderült, tehát
röpke másfél nap volt az, hogy
megcsináltuk a mamográfiát, egy vékony
tűzsopsziát, és szerencsém volt, hogy a
doktor úr azt gyorsított eljárással
kiértékelte.
Úgyhogy tehát szó szerint pár óra alatt
kimondtuk hangosan, hogy hát ez bizony
egy rákos daganat. Ez ez a pont, amikor
kimondjátok hangosan, ez az, amit te is
vártál hár hónapokig. Ez milyen milyen
érzés? Mi mi volt akkor? Mi mi
játszódott le bennetek?
Hát sok, tehát olyan sok, ami ami ahhoz
hasonló, hogy megnyílik egy-egy szelep a
talpadon, és gyakorlatilag kifolysz a
saját életedből. Legalábbis nekem ilyen
volt. Tehát azt éreztem, hogy egyáltalán
nem tudom, hogy merre van az előre. Hm.
Tehát nem tudom megfogni. Nem is meg se
tudtam fogalmazni. Tehát félelmet se
tudtam megfogalmazni.
Nem itt nem láttam
semmiféle módját annak, hogy ebből tehát
hova kell, melyik irányba kell
elindulni.
Tehát a így érdekes, ahogy fogalmaztál,
tehát a a félelem az nem a az a amit
elképzelnénk a domináns érzés akkor
ebben a pillanatban. Nekem nem volt,
tehát nem nem ez a nem is a félelem, az
nem magam irányában.
tényleg a legelső az az volt, amikor
tehát ahogy ott a kószöveton közölték,
hogy hogy Anna ez melk,
én ott ültem s ott azon kattogtam, hogy
mi lesz a gyerekeimmel. Tehát semmi de
semmi másra nem tudtam fókuszálni. Tehát
nem és hosszan nem fogalmaztam meg semmi
mást. Tehát ha utólag visszanézek, akkor
azt érzem, vagy a úgy tudnám
megfogalmazni, hogy tehát a létező
összes félelmet, amit meg kellett volna
fogalmazzak, benyomtam ez az egy mondat
mögé, és mint egy örvény úgy lerántott.
Nem, nem, még a meglévő alternatívákat
se láttam, pedig voltak, tehát lettek
volna, de tehát tényleg utólag mikor
jobban lettem, akkor úgy meg is
mosolyogtuk egyébként ezt a
gyerekeimmel, hogy én ott miért
gondoltam azt, hogy pótolhatatlan
vagyok, merthogy ha történt volna
valami, akkor is volt megoldás arra,
hogy őket lett volna aki felnevelje. De
hogy tehát ez nekem akkor nem tudtam
szabadulni, hosszan nem tudtam
szabadulni ettől, hogy hogy mi lett
tényleg ez volt, hogy minden nem volt
ilyen kérdés, hogy velem mi lesz, vagy
mik lesznek a kezelések, vagy hogy
mi fog történni, tehát hogy innentől
kezdve mi fog, mert nem is tudom, tehát
valahogy azt tudtam, hogy én fogok
kezdeni valamit ezzel, tehát elindul a
folyamat,
Belépnek az orvosok is, és meg fogják
mondani azt, hogy mit kell csináljak. És
és be is indul. Tehát ez egy kaotikus
állapot, mikor beindul, hogy
folyamatosan csak mindenki azt mondja,
hogy most kolozsvárra mész, MR-re mész,
CT-re mész, röngenre mész, újabb
biopsziák, hogy addig a pontig volt
nagyon-nagyon nehéz, amíg amíg elkezdtük
a kezeléseket. Tehát engem az őrölt fel,
hogy hogy annyi minden
történik, fogy az időm, közben nőtt a
csomó a mellemben, tehát a biopsziától
számítva mondhatnám azt, hogy
agresszívet. Ühüm. És még mindig csak
egyik hét a másik után ment el, és
mindig nem volt végleges eredmény, még
mindig nem kezdtük el a kezeléseket.
Kinga, a te esetedben ez hogy volt,
amikor meg amikor megtudtad a
diagnózist, azt visszaemlékszel gondolom
arra a pillanatra. Igen, érdekes volt,
mert hogy nekem nem ott, mivel hogy nem
lett ez így ki így kimondva nekem akkor,
hogy rákos vagyok, hanem hogy lett egy
rossz diagnózisom, tehát hogy én
éreztem, hogy baj van és
tudatávam, de hogy ezt valahogy úgy úgy
úgy mintha félretettem volna, hogy hogy
ez azért így nem lett kimondva. Én mikor
már műtétre mentem
Kolozsvárra, nagyon féltem attól, hogy
tehát, hogy én azért láttam az édesanyám
esetébe és az édesapám esetében is, hogy
hogy milyen kezeléselébe nézek, és az
volt a legnagyobb félelmem, hogy hogy
megműtenek, de hogy utána milyen
kezelések lesznek. És féltem nagyon a
kemoterápiától. Ühüm.
És emlékszem, hogy a
már be voltam utalva Kolozsvárra, és
akkor ott a rendelőbe az orvostól
megkérdeztem, hogy de hát doktor úr,
hogy hogyha megmutenek, akkor ugye én
nem kell kapja kemoterápiát.
és rám nézett, és egy ilyen egy
ilyen nem is tudom mondani,
hogy hát olyan olyan lazán úgy mondta,
hogy tehát hölgyemön
rákós. Tehát hogy ebben benne volt az,
hogy hát mégis mit képzelek én? Tehát,
hogy hogy hölgyem, hát na akkor volt az,
mikor úgy éreztem, hogy
hogy ki kapták alam a talajt. Én egy
óriási bénulttságot érz éreztem. Tehát,
hogy egy olyan
kiüresedést és egy egy olyan
bénultságot, tehát hogy éreztem, hogy
hogy lábam, kezem, minden is, és hogy
hogy ott megáll a levegő, és és hogy hát
akkor itt itt itt akkor most
tud lenni tovább.
És hogy tud lenni tovább? Ahogy mondtad
Anna, egy gépezetbe indul, ilyenkor
jönnek a a mindenféle információval,
hogy ez ekkor kell elkezdeni, ez lesz a
folyamat. Tehát van egy van egy
személytelen gépezet, mondjam úgy,
amelyik elindít ezen az úton, vagy nem
nem mondanám, nem nevezném
személytelennek. Tehát annak megvan a
pozitívuma egyébként a betegnek, hogy
hogy elkezdik megmondani neki. Tehát
mivel nem tudsz gondolkodni, tehát nincs
tiszta gondolkodás, tehát ha elkezdesz
gondolkodni, akkor szippantanak be a
félelmeid. Tehát jönnak kérdései
tömvelege, ami ami már nem csak a
betegséget érinti, hanem hanem a kihat,
tehát a környezetet bejönnek emberek.
Úgyhogy az, hogy a gépezet az így van,
így épül fel, hogy aztán a folyamata az,
hogy mindig megmondják, hogy mi a
következő lépés, ezt én tényleg úgy élem
meg, hogy hogy ez jó akkor ez egy
pozitívum. Igen. Jó, akkor ezt a hogy
képzeljem el, a környezeteteknek, hogy
mondtátok el ezt? Én én a
környezetemnek nagyon nehéz volt ezt
elmondani a közeli
hozzatartozóimnak, merthogy ott igazából
már ott meg kellett szűrjem, hogy kinek
mondom el, és kinek nem. Miért? Merthogy
a édesapám akkor
végstádiumú vastag bérrákban volt, és
édesanyám volt az, aki ápolta.
volt bennem egy ilyen
óvás a részemről, tehát hogy úgy
éreztem, hogy nem nem tudom én ezt
elmondani nekik, mertogy hogy ezt nem
bírnák ki édesanyámnak azért, mertogy
mikor ő beteg volt, akkor mindig azt
mondta, hogy ezzel vigasztalta magát,
hogy milyen jó, hogy ő beteg, és nem a
gyermekei. A másik pedig, hogy
édesapámnak már láttam azt, hogy hogy
neki közel van a vég, és féltettem, hogy
haraggal fog elmenni, tehát hogy Istenre
fog
haragudni, és hogy ezt nem szerettem
volna.
Úgyhogy igazából a
a gyermekem a ők nem tudták, tehát
édesapám úgy ment el, hogy nem tudta,
hogy hogy nekem daganatom
van. És édesanyámnak is akkor mondtam
meg, mikor már túl voltam én a műtéten.
Tehát, hogy Kolozsvárra úgy mentem el,
hogy hogy ők nem tudták.
aki akinek elmondtam a nővéremnek,
merthogy éreztem, hogy valakinek el kell
mondani. A nővérem tudott róla, hogy
műtétre megyek, és annak ellenére, hogy
külön voltunk már a gyerekem
édesapjával, úgy éreztem, hogy ő az,
akinek el kell mondjam, mert hát ha én
nem leszek, akkor az
édesapja kell a fiamra. Ö hát mindenki
mindenki megdöbbenve, tehát hogy
hogy
próbálják próbálják a
a reménnyel nézni ezt az egészet, de
hogy lesújtó, lesújtó.
és hogy a gyermekemnek is el kellett
mondani, hát egy egy kisgyereknek, aki
aki tényleg,
hogy más szerintem az is,
mikor olyan családban nőnek fel ezek a
gyerekek, ahol anyuka, apuka, testvérek,
de ahol csak anyuka van, ö hiába, hogy
ott van az édesapja, és teljes mértékben
részt vállal, de hogy hogy az az
Más a kapoc hány éves volt akkor
ezekkel a szám számokkal nem vagyok én
nagyon jó körülbelül tehát hogy mennyire
ká olyan nyolc hét hét nyolc éves. Igen,
igen. Igen. És azért is nehéz,
merthogy hogy még mindig ez van a a
köztudatban, tehát hogy a a ha valaki
rákos, kopasz lesz és meghal.
és hogy a gyerekek között is ez van.
Tehát, hogy nehéz egy olyan hét éves
gyereknek ezt szerintem majd nagyobb
akkor is nehéz, hogy hogy elmondani,
hogy igenis most ez ez egy daganat, amit
megműtenek. Anya igyekszik, hogy
végigcsináljon
mindent. Hogy ez nem kötelezően így van,
hogy anyakopasz lesz, és akkor meg is
hall.
De hát mikor azzal jön az az az
iskolából, hogy hogy azért ezt mondták a
az osztálytársak, hogy hát hogyha anya
kopasz, akkor meg fog
halni. Ne nehéz nehéz ezeket a dolgokat
úgy elmondani, hogy legyen benne egy kis
könnyítés nekik, hogy fel tudják
dolgozni ezt, vagy hogy tudjanak vele
létezni.
Tehát nehé láttam, láttam az ő
szenvedését mellettem. Nekem az volt a
nagyon érdekes. Most másképp mondanál
amúgy. Nem,
nem, nem. Én így visszatekintve az
életemre úgy gondolom, hogy mindent,
amit tettem, akkor ott
tartottam, ott tartottam
érzelmileg, elmével, felfogásilag.
Tehát, hogy hogy az az úgy jól volt,
ahogy volt, azt úgy jól tettem. Tehát de
a mostani tudásoddal kérdem, hogy most
másképp, ha mostani tudásoddal mennél
vissza az időbe, másképp mondanáz? Nem,
nem hiszem, hogy lehet ezt jobban
kozmetikázni, vagy kéne. De például
édesapádnak elmondanád-e? Nem, nem, még
most is nem. Határozottan nem
határozottan úgy, úgy tud úgy, úgy
hiszem, ahogy ezt nem nem kellett ő
tudja. Ühüm.
Anna, te a környezeted, hogy hát kicsit
kicsit könnyebb volt olyan szempontból,
hogy ugye mivel a diagnosztizálás nekem
a munkahelyemen történt
így tehát elsőként tényleg akkor hát ők
velem egy időben tudták meg, tehát mi
egyszerre tudtuk meg, visszament, tehát
tudták, hogy mi történik, hogy
biopsziára mentem be, és ott vártam a
munkahelyemen az eredményt, mondom, ami
tehát röpke három óra alatt Ott hát
sokkot kaptunk. Tehát ez ott
mindenki amúgy tehát egészségügyi
szakemberként
nehezebb helyzetben vagy. Tehát úgy
nehezebb helyzetbe, hogy hogy nincs mit
mondjál. Tehát nincs semmiféle mellé
beszélésnek helye. Tehát hiába mondod
azt a kollégádnak, hogy hogy meg fogsz
gyógyulni és igyáll több cégla, levecs,
gondolkodj pozitívan. Tehát ezt ők
mindenki tudja azt, hogy te is tudod,
hogy mivel állsz
szembe. Ez
tényleg szerencsés voltam, merthogy a
kollégáim ezt annyira reálisan reagálták
le. Tehát ott mi kimondtuk, hogy ez van,
ezt kell csinálni, aztán majd meglátjuk,
hogy mi sül ki belőle. Tehát ez így
indítani, ez
nekem nagy könnyebbség volt. Tehát az az
érzés, hogy van egy hely, ahol erről
lehet őszintén beszélni. Tehát ez
szerintem nagy segítség. És a kollégáim
ők
végig tehát végig végigjelen voltak.
Tehát fizikai segítség, gyakorlati
segítség, lelki támasz, soha nem
túlzásba, de ott voltak.
Ez közelebb is hozott egymáshoz a
kollégáid. Azt hisz, tehát igen, igen.
Tehát mi fontosak vagyunk egymásnak. Nem
tudom
ez tehát most ott is van egy mag, akik
akik figyelünk egymá jelen vagyunk
egymás életében. Így fogalmaznék.
És a többi fog sokkal, bocsánat, sokkal
nehezebb feladat az itt jött, mertogy én
haza kellett menjek. És itt most tényleg
nem a gyerekeimre gondolok.
hanem
édesanyámra. Tehát anyukám ott volt
nálam azért,
mert a gyerekem vakációnm volt, a
kislányom volt csak otthon, és ő volt
vele, és ő tudta, hogy azért kell ott
legyen, mert én megyek biopsziára. Tehát
emlékszem erre,
hogy hogy bementem a
templomba, tehát imádkozni nem tudtam,
de azon gondolkoztam, hogyha most
hazamegyek, akkor melyik utat kell
választani? Mert hogy ő vár engem haza
azzal, hogy mondok
valamit, és hogy azt mondjam-e, hogy hát
nincs eredményem, majd lesz valamikor,
és közben kitalálok valamit, vagy el
kellett dönteni, hogy elmondom a
kendőzetlen
igazságot. Úgyhogy hazamentem és
kimondtam, hogy édesanyám rákom van.
Úgyhogy azt hiszem, a legeslehezebb
szerep az ez, hogy szülőként és
anyaként szembesülsz azzal, hogy a
gyereked
rákos. Nem tudtunk mondani semmit, tehát
nem nem is volt helye ennek, hogy
mondjak én bármit, vagy ő mondjon
bármit. volt egy
ilyen tényleg egy ilyen
hallgatólagos,
csendes egyesség köztünk, hogy hogy
mindenki egyedül akar lenni. Tehát én is
azt szerettem volna, ha ő hazamegy, ő is
azt szerette volna, hogy hazamegyek, s
egyedül vagyok. Én is azt szerettem
volna, hogy otthon maradok s egyedül
vagyok, mert mert nem nem tudtunk mit
mondani. Tehát anyukám valahogy ebből a
csendből olyan, tehát egy csodaként
tudott visszalépni egyébként a
folyamatba, merthogy rá nekem óriási
szükségem volt. Tehát mellette voltak az
én gyerekeim biztonságban, mikor én
kezeléseken voltam. És olyan olyan szép
az, hogy ő ezt olyan elegánsan csinálta.
Tehát soha de soha nem volt hát de, vagy
hogy megreformálom az életedet, hanem
mindig megengedte, hogy megmondjam neki,
hogy ő hogy tud nekem segíteni. Tehát
soha nem jött azzal, hogy hát de, hanem
emlékszem a ahogy mondta mindig, hogy
jól van fiam, és mindig ott volt úgy,
hogy jól van fiam, akkor csináljuk.
gyerekeimnek pár nappal később mondtam
el, mert ahogy hazajött a fiam is, tehát
ezt tudtam, hogy egyszerre szeretném
nekik
elmondani. Ez
azon is sokat gondolkoztam, hogy hogy
kell jól elmondani. Tehát hogy tudod úgy
elmondani, hogy őszinte legyél és ne
legyél drasztikus. Tehát elmondani egy
drasztikus dolgot, nem drasztikusan. Ez
úgyhogy tudom, nekik nem mondtam ki,
tehát nekik azt, hogy rákos vagyok, ezt
nem is tudtam volna. Tehát annyira
szerettem volna megvédeni őket ettől,
hogy
de ha nem mondod el, ki fogja mondani
más. Tehát úgy ahogy Kinga is mondta,
itt végre aztán tőle tudták meg. Igen.
Tehát én ugye nagyon elegánsan
felvázoltam mosolyogva. hogyha anyának
találtak egy csomót a
mellébe, kezelést kell kapjon. A
kezelésnek a következménye az lesz, hogy
anyának el fog hullni a haja. Csak, hogy
egyértelmű volt, hogy az akkor 14 éves
fiam, tehát két szót értett, anya
rákos. És ezt hiába nem mondtuk ki,
tehát én is tudtam, hogy ő tudja, és ő
is tudta. Nem mondtuk ki.
A kislányom kilenc éves volt, tehát neki
nem körvonalazódott ez így otthon, mert
hál istennek nem volt rákos addig a
környezetünkben. Nem, ő nem fordította
ezt így le, de elmondta más. Tehát
hetente a végig a folyamat alatt
legalább egyszer úgy jött haza, hogy
anya XY azt mondta, hogy ha te kopasz
vagy, akkor rákos vagy. Ha rákos vagy,
meg fogsz halni.
hát nagyon-nagyon meg tudja nehezíteni
egyébként azt a helyzetet,
amíg el tudod neki magyarázni. Tehát ha
most azt mondom, hogy időnként esti mese
helyett ez volt a
beszélgetésünk, hogy a halál az nem
kímél senkit, tehát mindenki meghal, az
is meghal, aki nem rákos. És nem
feltétlenül kell meghalljon az, aki
rákos beteg, merthogy mindent azért
teszünk,
hogy
meggyógyuljunk. Nagyon-nagyon tehát én
nagyon-nagyon sokat gondolkoztam
egyébként ezzen, hogy tényleg, hogy kell
jól elmondani, de nagyon-nagyon
fontosnak tartom. Tehát pont a napokban
futottam bele egy hölgybe, aki most
derül ki, és kicsi gyereke van, és pont
ez volt a kérdés, hogy nem mondjuk el,
hogy tehát neki is elmondtam, hogy el
kell mondani. Tehát minden gyerek
korának az őszintjének megfelelően,
tehát ha nem kell kimondani, hogy rákos,
de azt, hogy itt valami rossz dolog
történik, merthogy a gyerek érzi, tehát
ő tudja azt, hogy itt rossz dolog
történik, de el kell mondani neki, ha
kicsi is, hogy most olyan dolog
történik, hogy anya fáradt, többet kell
pihenjen, hogy ő ne úgy fogalmazza meg,
hogy valami rossz történik, amiért
esetleg ő a hibás, tehát ő tehet róla,
mert nagyon gyakran a gyerekek így
fordítják le.
Az, hogy mi
erről, az, hogy elmondta Tamás, és mi
erről otthon kezdtünk
beszélni, ez most már
pozitívum. Tehát aztán az a nyitott
őszintesség, hogy nekünk belekeveredett
ebbe az, hogy én meghalok, te is
meghalsz, nincs
sorrend, hogy
és hogy mit tehet. Tehát az a
felismerés, és ezt tényleg köszönöm a jó
Istennek, hogy amikor így véletlenek
nincsenek, de eszembe jutott, hogy
elmondtam a kislányomnak, hogy te úgy
tudsz anyának a legtöbbet segíteni,
hogyha imádkozol
érte. És ez olyan fontos volt, merthogy
ő akkor azt érezte, hogy ő is tehet
valamit azért, hogy anyát segítse ezen
az úton. És megtették.
Milyen érdekes dinamikát indítottál? Ez
el is, tehát jelezte is, tehát olyan
minden kezelésemről rajzokkal várt haza,
hogy be kell vonni, tehát nem nem lehet,
nem ellehet, nem érdemes. Tehát nem
érdemes, mert a környezete könyörtelenül
közölni fogja vele, hogy hogy anyukád
rákos, hát a rákos meg fog halni. De hát
úgy ha tegyük fel most biztosak
lehetnénk benne, hogy a környezete nem
fogja közölni. Talán akkor is érdemes
feltenni a kérdést, hogy kell tudjon
róla vagy nem. Meg kell-e kiméljük mi az
élet nehézségétől, vagy én azt hallom,
hogy nem. Tehát el kell mondani nekik,
mert ez nem igaz, hogy a gyerek nem tud
mit kezdeni azzal. Tehát a gyerek, én
azt vallom, hogy sokkal
nehezebben birkózik meg a
bizonytalansággal,
mint az őszintes. Tehát ugyanúgy
működnek egyébként mi is. Tehát csak
felnőkként, felnőttként ezt elfelejtsük.
Tehát hajlamak vagyunk elfelejteni. Meg
neki az a természetes, ami nekünk
természetes. Tehát igen. Szerintem is
nagyon fontos, hogy a gyerekeknek
elmondjuk azt, hogy és hogy a tehát hogy
úgy elmondani a amilyen korban van ő.
amennyit meg kell értsen, tehát hogy nem
túlterhelni, de mindenképpen azt érezze,
hogy nem őhavás azért, mertogy anyának
most nincsen kedve mosolyogni, vagy
nincsen kedve játszani, vagy tehát hogy
másak lett, tehát hogy érzik azt, hogy
másak lettünk, és hogy ő ebben ne azt
gondolja, hogy
hogy és a másik az, hogy hogy
őszintének akarom nevelni a gyermekemet,
akkor én is őszinte kell legyek. Tehát,
hogy ez a példamutatás is ebbe az
egészbe. A másik, hogy tényleg, hogy a a
összeszedik ők ezt, hogy igenis azt
mondták, hogy hogy kopasz, meg fogsz
halni, és hogy tényleg ezt én is így,
ahogy elmondtam neki, hogy hogy nem
ettől függ. Tehát az, hogy mikor halunk
meg, mindenki meghal, és hogy nem ettől
függ, hogy most mikor leszek én
elszólítva.
De
hogy így is, így is megvolt az, hogy egy
szuper jó gyerek akart lenni, tehát hogy
ő ő ki akarta könnyíteni nekem azt, hogy
hogy ne legyen gondom vele.
És akkor egy olyan
ö megfelelni akarás volt benne, amit
amit nehéz volt
nehéz volt kezelni, hogy lecsitítani,
hogy én pont úgy szeretlek
ha egy rossz jegyet kapsz.
Szeretném azt is, ha betörsz egy
ablakot.
Tehát mindenképpen
szeretlek, hogy most ebbe vagyunk ennek
az életünknek ebbe az időszakába, de
attól függetlenül én azt érzem most is,
hogy teljes mértékben szeretlek, csak
hogy lehet, hogy nem úgy tudok
megnyilvánulni, mint idáig, ahogy
megnyilvánultam.
Ez az nagyon érdekes, így mind a ketten
említettétek azt, hogy ilyenkor a
fókusz, hogy ki mire fókuszálunk, amikor
az élet tragédiájával találkozunk. az
hol van? Mert az, akit el tudom
képzelni, egyedül él, nincs gyermeke, az
önmagára fókuszál. És gyanítom, hogy
nektek azért mégis csak erőt adott az,
hogy van felelősségetek az életben.
Nektek még
még figyelnetek kell másra. Van akiért
élni és van, aki van akire vigyázni. És
pont így gyakorlatilag most is ezt
mondtad, hogy a a kislányod a fókuszált
önmagáról rád helyezte. Kisfiam vagy
kisfiam, bocsánat. Ön magáról rá rád
helyezte.
Igen, de én ezzel nem értek egyet, hogy
annyira, hogy nekem például nem az volt
az első gondolatom, hogy hogy nem vagyok
pótolható. Én pont azt gondoltam, hogy
pótolható vagyok, és én nem a
gyermekemért, és nem édesanyámért, és
nem senkiért jöttem csináltam végig az
egészet, hanem magamért. Hm. Tehát, hogy
én én azt megéreztem ebbe az egészbe,
hogy én ha jól vagyok, akkor körülöttem
jól tudnak lenni az emberek, a közeliek,
a szeretteim. Ühüm. És nem volt ez volt
egy olyan érdekes mondat egy De meg
ebben a mondatban is azt hallom, hogy
hogy azért akarsz te jól lenni, hogy a
környezeted jó legyen. Igen, de hogy
elsősorban magamért. Igen, magamért,
mert hogy hogyha Igen, csak hogy más
volt a fókusz, tehát hogy hogy inkább
magamra Igen. Tehát hasonlóan bennem is
az, ha ha arra gondolok, hogy mint három
gyerekes családapa, azért akarok én
egészséges lenni, hogy a gyerekeimre
vigyázzak. Először rajtam van a
hangsúlyom, mert én akarok egészséges
lenni, de mégis most elképzelem, hogyha
egy teljesen egocentrikus, önmagamnak
élő életet élnék, ami csak rólam szól,
akkor a pánikroham egyből elfog, mert én
önmagamért élek, és én pusztulok el
önmagamban. Tehát ez a fajta centra
egocentrikus élet amúgy ezt ezt jó
párszor láttam más helyzetben is,
egyszerűen önpusztító abban a
pillanatban céltalanná tesz és
depresszívvé. Viszont amikor van, aki
érni van, azért kell én egészséges
legyek, mert a környezetem ezt összeg ad
egy erőt persze. Igen. Tehát, hogy ha
így vetítjük, ha úgy vetítjük a dolgot,
de hogy igen. A jelentősen megkönnyíti,
tehát mer nekem nagyon-nagyon
megkönnyítette a helyzetemet az, hogy
hogy ott van a két gyerek.
Igen. Tehát az, hogy tudtam azt, hogy
tehát az, amit teszek, azt teszem
magamért, de
értük, és hogy ott van, bele kell
kapaszkodni abba, hogy hogy akarom, hogy
ők ők is azt lássák, hogy megtesszük a
dolgokat egymásért is. Tehát tényleg
bele én bele tudtam kapaszkodni abb,
hogy ott van a két gyerek, akik akikért
felelősséget. Nekem akkor volt az
érzésem, hogy azelőtt az életemben
mindig első helyen volt mindig más a
gyermekem a és hogy itt akkor én első
helyre tettem magam. Mintogyha itt lenne
egy alapelvit mögötte kicsit
boncolgassuk, mert így hogy gyakran az
emberek hajlamosak másért többet
megtenni, még akár a kutyájukért is
többet tenni, mint saját magukért, hogy
hamarabb viszik el állott orvoshoz, mint
saját magukat.
hogy
diagnosztizálják
hogy tényleg mintogyha lenne egy ilyen
sorrendiség, hogy ahhoz, hogy jól
szeressem a másikat, először magamat
kell jól szeressem. Pontosan. Tehát ezt
adja a betegség egyébként. Tehát a
betegségben szerintem minden ember
megtanulja ezt. Tehát ez az egyik
tanulási feladat, hogy hogy zömében meg
is figyeltük sóstársakon, hogy a tehát
99%-ban elmondják magukról azok az
emberek, hogy hogy ők nem voltak
fontosak maguknak. Tehát mindenki fontos
volt, csak ők nem. Tehát ők valah ők is
csak ott, tehát én például magam,
önmagamhoz soha nem értem el. Tehát én
azt hittem, hogy fontos vagyok magamnak,
de annyi mindenki és annyi minden
fontosabb volt, hogy hogy nem értem elő
magamhoz. És hogy a betegség tényleg
megteszi azt, hogy te muszáj előtérbe
helyezd magad, merthogy a betegséggel
olyan állapotokba sodródsz, amikor
gyakorlatilag nem is tudsz te másra
figyelni, csak saját magadra. Tehát
olyan fizikai állapotokat élsz meg, hogy
hiába van ott körülötted a gyereked vagy
bárki, mert egyszerűen képtelen vagy
figyelni a
környezetedre, és ez tényleg
lefordított, tehát ezt aztán le is
fordítja az ember magának, mert
egyértelműen jön a megtapasztalása
ennek, hogy amikor jobban vagyok, akkor
mindenki jobban lesz. És hiába, hogy ez
így indul el, hogy csak a fizikai
tüneteknél figyeljük meg egyszer, hogy
akkor most tegnap rosszul voltam
mindenki, milyen stresszes volt, ma jól
vagyok, hirtelen így kisimul a víz,
mindenki jól van, és ezt beépítjük az
életünkbe. Tehát tarthatatlanul beépül
az életedbe, mert mindenkinek nagyon jó,
hogy és aztán el is kezdi játszani az
ember ezt, hogy jól vagyok, ők is jól
vannak. Tehát és akkor megteszed
magadért is. Tehát még ha nem is így
mondjuk ki, hogy jaj, most csak magamért
teszem meg, de hogy igen. Tehát erre
nagyon-nagyon figyelünk a
hétköznapjainkban. Most is az egyik
görcs bennem, amit lehet, hogy most
fogok tudni feloldani, az az, hogy ha
megtudom az egyik nem túl közeli
ismerősömről, hogy daganatos betegsége
van, mert hogyha közeli valószínűleg én
is így reagálnék csenddel,
elgondolkozással, az élet tragédiájáról
gondolkoznék, hogyan tudnék mellette
lenni, lehet, hogy azt jobban
kezelném, ki tudja. De mi a helyzet
azzal a a felmerül bennem a kérdés,
hogyha jön egy számomra távoli ismerős
és elmondja ezt és gondolom, hogy másban
is azért ez egy görcs, hogy hogyan kell
ezt lereagálni, hogy most túl drámai sem
akarok lenni, de elviccelni sem lehet.
Meg emlékszem, amikor édesapámnak a a
halálos betegségéről az egyik
szomszéddal beszéltem, akkor szegény
zavarában az a szomszéd azt mondta, hogy
na jó, mindegy. És akkor ment tovább. De
tudom, hogy nem rossz szándékkal
mondtam, de de már szinte vicces volt,
hog hogyan reagálta le, és
és én sem vagyok biztos benne, hogy
jobban reagálnám le. Tehát most ebben a
pillanatban, hogy adjatok nekem
tanácsot, hogyha most az egyik ismerősöm
ugyanezt elmondaná, hogy találtak egy
csomót a mellembe, és valószínűleg ez
egy rossz indulatú rákos daganat, akkor
hogyan kéne lereagáljam? Milyen mi lenne
az, ami mi mi az, amivel nem lennék túl
sértő, vagy túl drámai, vagy túl
felületes? Nem, nem, nem tudom, hogy
ilyenkor mi a szabály. Nincsen szabály
rá igazából, de hogy legtöbbször az
emberek nem
ö anélkül, hogy betegek
lennünk, nem tanácsra vagyunk
legtöbbször rászorulva, hanem a
meghallgatásra.
És itt szerintem ilyenkor felerősödik
az, tehát hogy mikor az ember annyira
elesett és
ekkora problémája van, hogy hogy
meghallgatásra
vágyik, meghallgatásra és együttérzésre
már amennyire telik a másik a másik
féltől,
merthogy nekem például nagyon nehéz volt
azért az az időszak, hogy úgy éreztem,
hogy nem értem. enek meg az emberek, és
át kellett el kellett eljenn átmentem
már egy jó pár szakaszon, amikor
felfogtam azt, hogy nem nem is szabad
megértsék. Nem is szabad megértsék, mert
aki
megérti az akkor benne van. Ühüm. Tehát
nem tudja megérni. Nem, nem és nem is
kell megérteni, de hogy kell
egy egy, hogy is mondja, tehát hogy egy
meghallgató kell igazából.
Igen. Tehát hogy érezze ma azt, hogy
hogy ott vagyok melletted, itt vagyok,
ha szükséged van rám.
Igen. És az is tehát az, hogy
távollabbi, tehát ugye megjelenik egy
ismeretlen ismerősként, ahogy
fogalmaztad, hogy tehát a ami ha a beteg
elmond bármit, tehát tényleg hallgató
legyen
és nem kell neki semmit mondani. Tehát
nem azért mondja el a beteg a bullyát,
bolját, hogy tehát vagy a problémáját,
hogy mert azt mondja, hogy na basszus
rákos vagyok, mert sokkal könnyebb
egyébként kimondani egy sokkal
távolabbinak. És itt
most eszembe jutott ez egy a legelső
napomon, és itt ezt azért mondom el,
mert itt lépett be, azt hiszem, a jó
Isten olyan formában, amikor azt mondom,
hogy nyilvánvaló formában nyilvánult
meg. Persze ez utólag láttam rá erre.
Amikor hazamentem, és anyukám hazament,
és én otthon maradtam egyedül, akkor
felhívott engem egy idegen. Tehát azért
mondom idegen, mert nem volt rokon, nem
volt közeli ismerős, nem volt
barátnő. Egy teljesen személyes szakmai
kérdéssel szeretett volna hozzám
fordulni. Az, hogy felvettem a telefont,
már ez egy csoda, mert nem szoktam én
ilyen helyzetekben felvenni a telefont.
Tehát felvettem a
telefont, köszönt, hallott a hangomon,
hogy valami nincs rendben, és neki
tényleg így tudtam kimondani, hogy na
nézd meg, basszus, mer rákon van, és nem
tudom, hogy merre van az
előre. És ez az
erről a személyől utólag kiderült, hogy
ő volt a földi őrangyalom. Tehát ő volt,
akit akkor ott abb a pillanatba
odahelyeztek mellém, merthogy tehát ez a
személy onnantól kezdve mindig akkor
jelent meg, amikor én
zuhantam. Tehát és mindig tudta, hogy
mit kell mondjon. Tehát spontánul nem
volt nem volt soha ilyen, hogy nem kell
kiosztani a beteget. Tehát a betegnek
nem kell megmondani a tutit. Tehát erről
ettől kell szerintem oszkodni, hogy
bármit mond ő. Tehát akár ha azt
kimondja, hogy félek, hogy meg fogok
halni, hogy nem kell leszedni a fejét,
hogy hogy nem fogsz, vagy hogy ő erről
nem beszélhet, vagy ha habos süteményt
akar enni, akkor nem kell neki azt
mondani, hogy ő nem ehet cukrot. Tehát
nem arra van szüksége, hogy ellássák
tanácsokkal.
A a Kolozsváron, mikor a műtétre, tehát
műtétről már
kijöttem, akkor éreztem egy
óriási egyedül vagyok érzést.
És ez nem azért, mertogy nem
számíthattam senkire, hanem azért,
mertogy igazából megvan ennek a
betegségnek, és talán minden betegségnek
az, mikor mikor azt érzi az ember, hogy
ebbe én egyedül vagyok
benne, és hogy
én nekem akkor volt, mikor én így is
mondhatom, hogy nevemen szólított Isten,
mikor kinyitották az ajtót, és magyarul
ott Korózsváron megkérdezték, hogy Kinga
itt fekszik-e a és bejött a
papnő. Akkor volt az az érzésem, hogy
egy percig sem vagy egyedül, egy
pillanatig sem vagy egyedül.
És az emberektől is igazából azt azt
vártam, hogy meglegyen ez, hogy nem kell
tanácsot adják, nem kell elmondani, hogy
hogy kell ezt
csinálni, mert kivált egy kívülálló, de
még még egy sorstársát tudja meg
megmondani, hogy ezt hogy kell
csinálni. Ezt nem lehet megmondani, hogy
hogy kell csinálni. Ezt mindenki úgy
csinálja, ahogy tudja.
Tehát nem tudom, nem lehet ezt mondani
egy betegnek,
hogy hát nézd meg, hogy XY milyen jól
bírja. Hát már túl van a kemoterápián,
és semmi nyűrögés, semmi nyafogással
végigcsináltak. Nem szabad ezt így így
összehasonlítani, hogy mindenki a saját
útján tudja ezt végigcsinálni. Nincsen
errecept, hogy ezt így vagy úgy kell
csinálni. Ezt úgy csinálja mindenki,
ahogy
tudja, a saját tempójába, a
saját eleséseivel, a saját mélységeivel
és magasságaival.
Mind a ketten
említettétek a hiteteket, hogy
imádkoztatok, és hogy ezt az űrt, amit
azt a magányt, mondjuk te nem említetted
a magányt, de el tudom képzelni, hogy
hogy ezt az az egyedüllét az teljes
tehát teljesen mindegy, hogy olyan
betegről beszélünk, aki fizikailag is
egyedül van, tehát kevés ember van
körülötte, vagy ott van körülötte az
egész rokonság. Mert
tehát ebben a folyamatban egyedül vagy
és nem is tudod másként csinálni, csak
egyedül tudod csinálni. Tehát egyedül
lehet ezt jól csinálni. Akkor
megfordítom a kérdést,
hogy hogyan változott a
hitetek, vagy előtte nem tudom, hogy
hogy hívőnek tartottátok-e magatokat,
vagy hogyan éltétek ezt meg, de egy
kicsit mesélnétek erről a folyamatról,
hogy mi történik, amikor ezt az űrt,
ahogy mondtátok, Isten tölti be? Én
azelőtt is olyan családba nőttem föl,
ahol nagymamám, ő ilyen templomba
járó mama volt, és hogy minket vitt
templomba. Tehát, hogy nem igaz, hogy
nekem nem volt kapcsolatom
Istennel, de hogy ez egy ilyen kis
langyos
néha
jó elő dögélni a templomba és
megnyugodni kapcsolat
volt. Ö mikor ott
megtapasztaltam, hogy
hogy nem egyedül vagyok én ebben, hanem
ott van az isteni
gondviselés,
ö nyitottabb
lettem, de hogy akkor még nem mentek
ezek az
imák, nem imádkoztam, vagy nem volt
ilyen ilyen nem alakult még akkor ki egy
ilyen szoros
kapcsolat, hanem csak ott is ez
A meghallgató Isten volt, aki vagy az a
csendes Isten volt, aki ott ott volt az
én ágyam mellett, vagy az én szenvedésem
mellett. De nem voltál már magányos, nem
voltál Nem voltam magányos. Tudtam, hogy
hogy ott van velem.
És ebbe a ebbe
a ebbe a
szeretetbe csináltam már
végig, és jobban figyeltem arra, hogy
hogy miket kapok ajándékokat az idő
alatt.
Utána kezdtem észrevenni a kis
ágacskákat, a kis csillagocskákat, ahogy
én neveztem, akik megjelentek az
életemben. Tehát úgy voltak olyan olyan
úgy mondtam én a csillagocskák, hogy
megjelentek csak egy 10 percre az
életemben, de hogy abba bele kellett
annak a fénybe kapaszkodni, és én azokat
a fényeket összegyűjtögettem.
És ez erőt adott a következő napra és a
következő kezelésre, és így tovább.
Egy-egy felcsillanó dolog, ami egy-egy
felcsillanó dolog, tehát amibe amibe
tényleg, hogy az ember meg tud
kapaszkodni. Nyitottabb lettem,
engedtem, hogy hogy beáradjon, de el
tudom képzelni, addig is voltak, azelőtt
is voltak, csak egyszerűen elrohan
mellett. Nem úgy elrohanunk mellette,
nem vesszük észre, lelassítjuk az
életünket. Akkor igazából lelassult az
életünk, megá megállította az Úr a a
rohanást, és akkor úgy úgy ahogy
megállunk és lelassulunk, akkor igazából
mikor mondtam, hogy hogy egy bénultságot
éreztem valójában ahogy a ani Ani
barátnőm szokta mondani, hogy egy
képzelt kormányzást veszítettem el, mert
azt képzeltem, hogy az én kezemben van a
kormányzás, ami valójában nem az én
kezemben volt addig. se. És most egy
olyan pár hónapja, hogy ez ötlött fel
így bennem, hogy
milyen jó, hogy nem én kell
kormányozzak, és nem én kell vezessem az
autót, mert ugyebár mennyivel jobb az
anyósi ülésen ülni, ha az ember
kormányoz, akkor csak a célt látja és az
utat.
Viszont ha az anyós ülésen én nyug
nyugodtan hátra tudok dőlni, akkor annyi
szépséget észreveszek én útközben.
Azt is mondtad, hogy lelassult így a
világ körülötted. Igen. Igen.
Határozottan. És ez akkor azt jelenti,
hogy az idő
érzéked lett, mondjam úgy intenzívebb,
mintogyha intenzívebben élnéd az életed?
határozottan intenzívebben. Én már az
első betegségem első évében azt mondtam,
hogy annyit éltem, mint azelőtt az
összes
életemben, merthogy olyan
intenzitással. Azt egy nagyon-nagyon
erős élményem volt, mikor banálisnak
tűnik. Egy alkalommal már mikor
sugárkezelésről jöttünk haza, és a
mostani párom hozott haza. Ő
felajánlotta volt, hogy akkor még nem
voltunk kapcsolatban, de hogy
felajánlotta, hogy ő segít, ő is egy
csillag az életemben. És megálltunk
szovátán, és akkor kezdtek árulni ilyen
kürtös
kalácsaba fagy fagyét fagy és megvettünk
egy-egy fagyit, tehát hogy nem egy
gombócot, hanem tele azt a kürdös
kalácsot. És ahogy leültem az első
padra, és ahogy csöpögött a a fagylalt a
könyökemen, és csorgott, és ettem a
fagyit, és egy olyan erős
életérzés, hogy istenem, én most eszem
ezt a fajlalt, üllök, itt süt a nap.
mellettem egy egy ember, akinek
számítok, és hogy olyan csodálatos érzés
volt. És szerintem itt itt ez ez, hogy
hogy tényleg, hogy ezeket a
pillanatokat, hogy ennyire meg tudom meg
tudom fogni és meg tudom élni.
Ez azóta is. Ben tudok. Igen, azóta is.
Igen, igen, igen. Tehát, hogy én egy
fecske röptébe, vagy egy pillangó
röptébe, vagy egy virágszirmába én
ennyire meg tudom élni. Hm.
Ez erre visszatérünk mindjárt, de egy
kicsit még poncolgatnám, leszek egy
kicsit az ördög ügyüdje, hogy Jungal
ellentétben Freud, ő egy ateista valaki
volt, és ő azt mondta a vallásokról,
hogy azért kell a vallás, mert a
halálfélelemre ez egy gyógyír, és hogy
az ember, mivel mulandó és és
előbb-utóbb lesz halálfélelme, ezért a
vallást találta ki, és használja arra,
hogy megmeneküljön ettől a a
halálfélelemtől. Tehát mint eszközt
találtuk ki saját magunknak a vallást.
Én most nem úgy érzem, mintogyha ti
eszközként használnátok ezt. Nyilván,
hogy hogy alakított a hiteteken, vágis
bólogattál í végig, és mindjárt akkor át
is adom a szót neked. De hogy azt
hiszem, és minden tiszteletem amúgy
Freudé, tehát egy zseni volt. Én most
így egy paprikajancs innen székely
udvarhelyről nem akarom megítélni
Freudot, de azt hiszem, hogy ebben
tévedett Freud, hogy a vallás nem egy
ilyen kitalált dolog, ami ami segít
nekünk fiktíven, hanem valami valósat
tapasztaltatok meg, hogy hogy ez a ez a
ez az, ami amit te megtapasztaltál, ez
nem egy nem egy hallucináció, nem egy
odaképzelt valami. Te ezt hogyan élted
meg? Nem. Tehát a én addig azt hittem,
hogy jó a kapcsolat. Én addig is azt
hittem, hogy jó a kapcsolatunk a jó
Istennel. Tehát tényleg vallásosan
neveltek, jártunk
templomba. Jól jól voltunk, tehát
gyakoroltam, tanítottam a gyerekeimnek
is. Viszont úgy fogalmaznék, hogy
teljesen átminősült és pozitív irányba.
Tehát az, amit
amit én megtapasztaltam, tehát azt a
jelenlét a jó Istennek a az életemben,
tehát úgy mind a az egész lényemben, az
min minden rezzenésben az ha csak ennyit
tanultam volna meg, vagy csak ha ennyi
hozadéka lenne a betegségemnek, akkor is
én most itt kimondom, hogy megérte. Nem
volt ez ilyen fényes út. Tehát
azért maradjunk annyiban, hogy
szerintem belefutunk eb én belefutottam
ebbe a problémába, mondjam így, hogy
akkor, amikor kiderült a betegségem,
akkor nem is azt mondanám, hogy
megharagudtam, tehát nem nem volt időm.
Tehát a olyan úgy pörögnek az események,
hogy mész orvostól orvosig, hogy fizikai
időm nem volt arra, hogy hogy meg tudjak
állni. Tehát tudni kell, hogy én addig
mindig csak a csendbe tudtam kapcsolódni
a jó Istennel. Tehát szükségem volt a
csendemre ahhoz, hogy azt higgyem, hogy
mi csak ott tudunk kapcsolatba kerülni,
és ott megszűnt a csendem. Tehát
emlékszem, hogy mikor kezdtek megjelenni
a kérdések, hogy jaj, mit tudunk
segíteni, én tényleg mindenkinek azt
mondtam, hogy megkérlek szépen,
imádkozzatok értem, mert én nem tudok.
És volt egyébként nekem is egy eléggé,
tehát azt mondom, hogy amikor aztán
tényleg belépett a jó Isten, úgy jó
rendesen belépett, vagy jó rendesen meg
én hazavittem a gyerekeimet
anyukámhoz, mert közben éreztem
folyamatosan, tehát végig a nagy
káoszban éreztem azt, hogy meg kéne
állni. Tehát meg kéne állni
valahogy szóba kéne el kellene elegyedni
a jó Istennel, hogy hogy meg akarom
hallani, hogy ő mit mond, mi az én
dolgom ebbe, mit kell megtanuljak. Tehát
ott ismét volt egy ilyen, hazavittem a
gyerekeimet
anyukámhoz. Hát emlékszem, hogy
hazamentem, bezártam az ajtót, és
mondtam, hogy hát istenem, itt vagyunk
te és én, és én, és te.
És ott akkor következett egy jó hosszú,
hangos monológ, tehát amikor én
úgy mondtam, tehát szerintem ott volt
minden, tehát volt számonkérés, volt dű,
kijött, tehát nem nem a jó Istenre
zúdítottam rá, tehát abba csendbe bele
azt, hogy hogy a ott jöttek ki nekem a
miértek. Tehát nem is ez volt, hogy
miért én, tehát a minden miért, miért
nem vagy, hogy foglak megtapasztalni.
annyira
elfáradtam ebbe a harcba, vagy ebbe a
vitába, hogy emlékszem, hogy leültem a
földre és így hallgattam azt a azt a
nagyon nagy csendet, tehát olyan síri
csend, ami úgy nem is létezik, azt
hisszük. És olyan érzésem volt, hogy
mosolyog a jó
Isten. Hát mondom, nem hiszem el. Hát te
nevedsz rajtam. Hát tehát tényleg. És
mosolygott a jó Isten. Tehát egy olyan
olyan erő volt bennem. Tehát én a nem
tudom megfogalmazni azt az érzést, ami
nyugalom. Tehát betöltötte a teret szó
szerint a jó Isten. Tehát kint, bent
mindenhol, mindenhol csend lett. Tehát
kívül is csend lett, belül is csend
lett. És én innen, ahogy
felegyenesedtem, én onnantól kezdve,
tehát a most eddig a pillanatig nem
többet nem volt soha
kétsége. Tehát az, amire azt mondjuk,
hogy hát vannak kétségeim, vagy tehát
nem is volt már ez, hogy amíg nincs
kétséged abban, Isten jó, hogy Isten jó,
és hogy ott van. Tehát akkor is ott van,
hogyha én egy helyzetet nem jónak ítélek
meg, és hogy abban a nem jó helyzetben
is
ő abból is jót fog
kihozni, tehát hogy nincsenek rossz
helyzetek.
Milyen szép í, ahogy elmondtad, tényleg
megérintő, ahogy így így így mesélsz
róla, hogy valójában az igaz keresztényi
út, abban benne van a birkózás, úgy
ahogy Jákob birkózott a Isten
angyalával, Istennel. És
hogy én is így tapasztalom, hogy Isten
ezt várja tőlünk, hogy legyünk
szenvedélyesek, hogy legyünk vagy
forróak, vagy hidegek, döntsük el, és
hogyha haragosak vagyunk, akkor
megbírja. És hogyha és és ez a fajta
igazi birkózás, ez az ami ami ami ami
amit így kiéreztem ebből a Igen. És hogy
nem szabad félni. Tehát a jó Isten nem
azért van, hogy mi féljünk tőle. Tehát
nem nem félelmet akar generálni ő
bennünk, hanem ő ott van, jelen van.
és mindig megengedi nekünk azt, hogy
hogy mi is abba a kapcsolatba tegyük
bele magunkat, de viszont bele kell
tegyük magunkat. Tehát most, hogyha csak
a betegségre levetitek, akkor
tényleg
ez így téves, hogy most valaki beül a
fotelbe és azt mondja, hogy jaj, nem
csinálok semmit, majd a jó Isten
megsegít. Tehát ez hibás szerintem, mert
a jó Isten akkor tud nekem segíteni,
hogyha én teszem a dolgomat. Igen. És a
dolgainkat előkbeesszik. Tehát nagyon
nagyon megváltozik egy éves. Tehát a
passzivitás az nem egy helyes. Az nem.
Tehát az nem az nem jó út. Nem nem vezet
el se a gyógyulás irányába, se a jó
isten irányába. Nem tud elvesz. Igen. A
passzivitása sehova nem vezet. Tehát
hiába hiába mondja azt valaki, hogy jaj,
de ő hiszm,
mert bele kell tegyük a saját részünket.
Tehát ehhez ad ő nekünk erőt. Tehát én
legalábbis ezt éreztem akkor onnan,
amikor fel tudtam egyenesedni, hogy hogy
nekem ő most minden erőt megadott ahhoz,
hogy én innentől kezdve minden egyes
lépésemnél meg tudom tenni. Tehát ha azt
mondják, hogy kemo, ha azt mondják, hogy
műtét, ha bármi csavar bejön ebbe a
dologba, azt ahhoz van nekem erőm
megtenni, merthogy én kapom tőle az erőt
minden lépésemhez. Egy dolog tiszta,
tehát hogyha azt mondjuk, hogy Isten jó,
nyilván az első gondolata az embereknek
az, hogy hogy engedhet meg egy jó Isten
egy ilyen tehát most nyilván egy
daganatos betegség az még ahhoz képest
kicsi, ami mint mint például Auschwitc.
Hogy engedhettem meg Ausvicot? Ez az
örök kérdés, ez az örök dilemma, amivel
küzd egy egy keresztény, aki küzdáltalán
bármivel is, hogy erre kaptatok-e
választ? Hogyan engedhette meg veled,
hogy ez megtörténjen? Mert megengedő
Isten
megengedi. A Bibliában is van, nem tudok
én idézni a Bibliából, de ott is van egy
olyan, mikor megkérdezik Jézustól, hogy
miért van, és azt mondja, én nem tudom.
Nekem például
a a halállal, hogy
szembenéztem, hogy ezek a történések
bejöttek az életembe,
úgy érzem, hogy
meghívott Isten arra,
hogy kapcsolódjak jobban az
élethez, hogy jobban megéljem a
pillanatokat. at, hogy jobban megéljem
és jobban értékeljem a tőle kapott
időt. Én ezt kaptam tőle. Tehát, hogy ez
ez az erős, tehát tényleg a a halállal
való
szembenézés. Jobban tudom értékelni az
időt. Én ezt az ezt az ajándékot kaptam
el az Istentől.
Akkor most vissza is térek az alapvető
kérdésemhez, ami amúgy foglalkoztat most
is, hogy hogyan tud az ember éber
maradni. Időnként megtörténik velem
például az, hogy valamiért felébredek.
És például volt olyan eset, amikor a
feleségemmel az autóban egy hajszál hián
úsztuk meg, hogy hogy egy nagy és
állapotos volt a kisfiammal, és egy
hajszál hián úsztuk meg, és szinte még
az én hibámon kívül is csúszott az út
meg satöbbi. A lényeg az, hogy utána
nagyon sokat gondolkoztam ezen, és egy
pillanatra felébredtem, és vannak éber
pillanataim, de sokszor kell
magamat, tehát sokszor kapom magam azon,
hogy hogy elkalandoztam, hogy bele
szőttem a a vágyaimat a jelen
pillanatban is a a megvakultam, és és
valójában nem veszem észre azt a sok
csillagot, ahogy fogalmaztál a
környezetemben, azt a csillámló
ajándékot, és
és olyankor hálátlannak érzem magam, és
az Ez a kérdésem, és elmondom mindjárt,
miért kérdezem ezt ez személyes szinten,
de mint szervezetfejlesztéssel
foglalkozó
személy, mint vezető, azt látom, ugyanez
történik cégkultúrákkal is, hogy
cégkultúrák is hajlamosak elaludni,
hajlamosak eltompulni, hálátlanná válni
és érvényes ez nemzetekre is, hogy
időnként nemzetek felébrednek és
visszaalszanak, felébrednek és
visszaalszanak. Hogy hogyan lehet
örökkéber maradni? Nem lehet, szerintem
nem vagyunk tökéletesek. Milyen de azt
mondtad, hogy neked már évek óta ez
sikerül.
Én úgy képzelem az életem, mint a rég,
tehát én falusi gyermek voltam,
és voltak régebok a ráfos kerekű
szekerek, amelyek úgy kijárták a a és
hogy egy olyan mélyedésbe ment a szekér.
És akkor hogy ne érje az alját, onnan ki
kellett a gazda vegye a szekeret, hogy a
lovak ne ott menjen. És én most is
érzem, hogy bizon, hogy én visszamegyek
én abba a de hogy észreveszem, merthogy
én már tudom azt, hogy észre kell
vegyem, merthogy én nem akarok ezen az
úton menni, merthogy eléri a az alját
majd a a a szekérnek. Tehát egy
folyamatos visszatérés. folyamatos
visszatérés van, mertogy én például a
hitem, tehát hogy én amikor nekem
megjelent Isten az életemben, nekem egy
nagyon türelmes Istenem van. nekem azt
mutatta meg azt az arcát. Ő türelmesen
várta, amíg én végigcsináltam a
kezeléseket, és nem voltakodó, és nem
volt számonkérő, hanem várta, hogy én
ezen az időszakon legyek túl, hogy mi
tudjunk személyes kapcsolatot kezdeni. Ő
a
csendes, engem megváró Isten
volt. És ő nem várja el azt, hogy hogy
mindig én ott menjek az
únal, hogy a kerekem ne csússzon vissza.
De azt elvárja, hogy visszatérj.
Elvárja. Igen, igen, igen. De hogy egy
türelmes jó istene, tehát nem a
büntető szigorú apaisten, hanem egy egy
jó, aki örv, hogyha visszatérsz, és
hogyha aki örül, hogy visszatérek én
arra az útra, ahol ami ami az ő útja.
És nem baj, hogy hogyha visszacsúszok,
és azért nem fog megbüntetni,
hanem örvendezik ő, hogy hogyha én
visszatérek arra.
Te ott te is akartál mondani, hogy
valamit láttam az arcodra? Igen. Tehát
így a az
alapkérdésre azon gondolkodom, ugye,
ahogy feltetted, hogy igen, tehát a jó
Isten megengedi, tehát ugye ezt nagyon
gyakran
megfogalmazzuk, hogy miért engedi meg.
Tehát
miért engedi meg, hogyha azt mondjuk,
hogy ő jó, de hogy én úgy gondolom, hogy
itt jön be az, hogy tényleg a jó Isten
szabad akarattal felruházott minket, és
emiatt ő megengedi azt, hogy és akár egy
ausvicci történés is ébredés, tehát egy
nemzetnek az
ébredése miatt kell megtörténjen. Tehát
a nagyon negatív dolgokat
mondom így gondolom, hogy azért engedi
meg, merthogy az egy esély arra, hogy
hogy fel tudjon ébredni egy ember, egy
nemzet, egy
közösség. Az, hogy
visszaalszunk, hát ez tényleg egy nagyon
gyarló emberi tulajdonságunk. Tehát ez
jellemzi gyakorlatilag szerintem most a
világot, hogy hogy alszunk vissza.
Mert tényleg nagyon sok ébresztése volt
nemzeteknek. Tehát csak rá kellene
egyébként csak rá kellene nézni. Tehát
annyira annyira világos, hogy ott vannak
az ébresztések. Tehát olyan dolgok
történnek a nagyvilágban is, hogy néha
arra csodálkozol rá, hogy hogy nem
ébrednek fel. Tehát ez, hogy tudunk
ébren maradni, ez erre tényleg az a
tudatosság kell, hogy ébren tartom
magam. Tehát mindig figyelm,
figyelmeztetem magam arra, hogy és
minden
történést ben rögtön azt látom, hogy na
már megint egy kicsit elaludtam, akkor
ébredni kell. Tehát, hogy ne, mert
olyan, ami szintén megfigyelhető nagyban
is. Tehát tényleg ezt hozom fel
példának, hogy milyen érdekes, hogyha
valami jó történik az életünkben. Tehát
amikor valaki csinál egy tuti
dolgot, nagyot
alkot, és azt mondja, hogy én voltam.
juj, hát nézd meg, hogy én mekkorát
alkottam, én csináltam, de ami egy
pillanatban történik, az életünkben
valami rossz. abb a pillanatba
kihárítjuk a jó Istenre a felelősséget.
Hát igen, mert a jó Isten ezt így
akarta. Tehát ezt szerintem mindannyian
halljuk, szinte nap mint nap
emberektől, hogy hogy ezt
kell
átfogalmazni, hogy a jót sem én
csináltam, tehát a jóra se lettem volna
képes, hogyha ha jó Isten nem mutatja
meg nekem azt a jót. Sőt, lehet, hogy ha
ha magamra ismerek a bűneimre, lehet,
hogy a rosszat én okozom, és minden, ami
jó, az persze tehát igen, a szabad
akarat. Tehát én odateszik a jót is és a
rosszat is. És
van egy kicsi döntési jogom, tehát nem a
betegségre utalok, mert azt úgy kapjuk,
tehát nem döntöm el, hogy most beteg
akarok lenni, de hogy
azon belül mit kezdek azzal, vagy mit
fogok csinálni, vagy azt, hogy fogom
csinálni, ott azért már van nekem
döntési jogom. És tényleg, tehát itt a
tényleg ez a hogy mindenben, tehát a
jóban is ott van, a rosszban is ott van
a jó Isten. Tehát ne ez legyen, hogy a
jót én, a rosszat ő adta, aztán jaj, hát
miért is? Hát nem érdemeltem meg. De hát
ez ez így nem igaz,
mert mert ott van a tehát ott van a a
rossznak megít. Tehát én úgy
fogalmaznék, hogy mondjuk azt, hogy nem
rossz dolgok vannak, hanem tanulnivaló
feladatok.
Tehát nem rossz dolgok történnek, hanem
azért történnek, hogy felismerjünk, hogy
felébredjünk, és addig fognak ezek
történni, amíg fel kell ébredjünk,
merthogy szerintem ez az egyik legfőbb
feladatunk.
Igen. Így amikor magamra gondolok, és
sokszor arra gondolok, megint ugyanaz az
elv, amit mondtam, hogy magamért sok
mindent nem tennék meg, de miért kell
éber legyek? is ugyanez a gondolat,
hogy ha én éber vagyok, akkor a
környezetemet tudom szolgálni, akkor egy
áldás tudok lenni a környezetem számára.
És igazából mi a felső határa egy
embernek? Mennyire lehet éber egy ember?
Jézus mennyire volt éber? Vajon ő hogy
eszi a fagyit minden egyes alkalommal?
És vajon hogyha sokkal éberebb lennék,
mint most, ahogy éber vagyok, akkor
annak milyen következményei lennének? Én
a mai reggel árajánlatokkal
foglalkoztam, mindenféle tárgyalásokkal
foglalkoztam, és úgy éreztem, hogy
beszűkíti így a a tudatomat, mert mert
az most a jelenre vonatkozik ebben a
pillanatban. És vajon hát ezután a
beszélgetés után sokkal könnyebb lesz
visszamenni és azt foglalkozni ezekkel,
mert már az a stressz nem nem lesz
rajtam, hogy hogy mert az árajánlat az
az csak egy az csak egy ideiglenes
valamiért nem nem fontos. Igazán nem
fontos, hogy és akkor ez így rávetíti a
felteszi a kérdést, hogy hogy akkor mi a
fontos? És tényleg akkor mi a fontos?
Tényleg ti erre mit válaszolnátok, hogy
most mi a fontos az életetekben? A
jelennek a megélése, a pillanatnak a
megélése. Ez
fontos. Hm. Hogy élni?
Itt vita az, hogy úgy éljünk, mintogyha
ez lenne az utolsó nap, de hogy az nekem
jobban tetszik, hogy úgy éljed,
mintogyha az első lenne.
az, hogy miért is engedi meg a az Isten,
hogy ezek megtörténjenek. Én még egy
másikat is
úgy úgy eszembe jutott egy másik dolog
is, hogy talán az
érzékenyítés, tehát hogy én, hogyha ezen
átmentem, akkor jobban tudok rezonálni
azokkal az emberekkel, akik ugyanebb
vannak. Tehát, hogy hogyha én azt úgy
élem meg egy rossz dolgot, hogy én abból
tanulok, lehet, hogy majd egy év múlva,
vagy két év múlva, ha találkozok
egy beteg, akkor már tudom, hogy hogy
most mit kéne csináljak, hogy csak most
kell hallgassak, vagy elmondjam azt,
hogy én nem tudom, hogy te hogy vagy
ebbe a helyzetben, de én abb a
helyzetben úgy csináltam,
hogy vagy én se tudtam, hogy ebben a
helyzetben mit kell
csinálni. És meg tehát hogy ez, hogy
mondjam, csak egy simogatás, egy
léleksimogatás és lehet, hogyan nem kell
több, de hogy bennem van már ettől a
tapasztalástól ez az
érzékenyítés, tehát egy sebzettség, egy
sebzettség, amit amit amit amit tudok
vállalni, mertogy ott marad a
sebzettségem. Ott marad a heggem, amit
amit tudok. Amúgy azt lehet mondani,
hogy kigyógyultatok, és ez ez ilyenkor
hogy képzeljem el? Ez biztos, hogy hogy
vagy hogy én még a kérdés sem tud felte
volna. Tehát ez ez az a van olyan pont,
amikor azt mondja az orvos, hogy na itt
már vége, itt van, van. Tehát ha az,
hogy az orvos azt mondja, olyan van.
Tehát ők azért így menesztenek minket az
onkológiákról, hogy és ez nem jó. Tehát
ez nagyon nehéz a betegnek ez a pont,
amikor én emlékszem, amikor a sugár
után, és még volt egy pár injekcióm,
tehát úgy 12-3 hónap után kimondták,
hogy jaj, hát most már rendben vagy,
tehát menjél ügyesen haza, meg vagy
gyógyulva. Hát ez egy másik mélypont.
Tehát azt gondolná az ember, ilyenkor
pezsgőt nyit kész. Ja. Ja. Tehát azt
hiszed, tehát én is azt hittem, és nem
is igazán. Tehát emlékszem, amikor az
onkológus doktornő állt szembe, és
mondta, hogy hát de Anna örüljön. Hát
mondtam, hogy örüljön a doktornő. Hát én
nem tudok. Hát nem tudom, minek kell
őrüljek,
mert nagyon nehéz visszalépni az életbe.
Tehát ez a folyamat után vissza kell
lépni a hétköznapi életbe, és nem tudod,
hogy azt hogy kell csinálni. Tehát arra
senki útmutatót nem ad, hogy történt egy
óriási nagy törés, valami történt az
életedben. Tehát szó szerint te mentél
egy úton, ami egy út volt ahhoz, hogy
meg fogok halni.
És akkor egyszer azt mondják neked, hogy
ez így lejárt, tehát te már nem halsz
meg. Nem most. És most ügyesen
visszafordulsz, és ott folytatod az
életedet, vagy ott kell nem tudod
eldönteni. Tehát ez
olyan, ez megint egy ilyen mélypont
volt. Nál mozgóba kéne beülem az
teljesen. Tehát nekem nagyon nehéz volt
az, hogy
én kaptam helyet Kolozsváron a kórházba,
még
sugárkezelésre kellett járni, és hogy a
kórházban voltam én az idő alatt. Ez hat
hét. Hat hétről van szó, tehát hosszú
idő. És
azt hiszem, hogy erre jó szó a
hospitalizáció. Tehát, hogy észrevettem,
hogy ugye voltak, akik a kortteremből
hamarabb jöttek és hamarabb kellett
menjenek haza, és hogy nem akartak menni
haza. Üm, és nem az, hogy hogy jaj, de
jós, hogy mindjárt itt van és meg, hanem
látszott, hogy hogy kezdek szorongani,
és hogy félnek, hogy lesz, mert ott
megkaptuk a reggelinket, az ebédünket, a
vacsoránkat, legyengült
emberekről beszéljünk, akinek nagyon
nagy hála van a szívében, hogy valaki
megfőzi az ételt, és mikor, hogy haza
kell menni, és hogy én ezt meg tudom-e
csinálni. Tehát, hogy ilyen egyszerű
dolgokat, hogy én most fogok tudni
takarítani a gyermekemnek, fogok tudni
főzni, tehát hogy alapvető dolgokat meg
tudok-e csinálni. Plusz még az mellett,
hogyha én itt vagyok a kórházban, és
bármi történik, akkor itt helybe vagyok.
Igen. És akkor vigyáznak rám. De hogy
hogyha hazakerülök, akkor jaj, Istenem,
akkor hova fogok én menni? Igen. És
ezzel, hogy ugye azt mondják, hogy
gyógyult vagy. Bár mi most már azért azt
mondjuk, hogy gyógyultak vagyunk. Tehát
ezzel nem zárjuk azt ki, hogy ez
bármikor bekövetkezhet. Tehát ezt el is
mondják, hogy nem, tehát a két dolognak
nem feltétlenül kell köze legyen
egymáshoz, nem zárja ki egyik daganat a
másikat, de hogy nagyobb eséetek van egy
újabb daganatnak, mint mint mint az
átlagemberlenül mond. De hogy igen.
Tehát na azért aki egyszer volt
daganatos beteg, az abban ott maradt
tarthatatlanul az, hogy vele ez bármikor
megtörténhet újból. Tehát ahányszor
kontrollra megyünk, azok nagyon nagyon
nagy
ez fél évente, hát eleinte három három
havonta kellett menjünk, aztán utána fél
évente majd egy évre el vagyunk engedve.
De hogy ez mindig ez mindig egy óriási
nagy harc és ez egy mélypont, mikor kell
menni kontrollra a környezet, hogy
minden rendben lesz, minden rendben
lesz. De hát ezt próbáljuk elmagyarázni,
hogy ez sértő amúgy, hogyha valaki azt
mondja, minden rendben lesz. Most már
nem nem nem sértő, inkább elcsételt,
vagy így. Tehát nem kell azt mondani,
hogy minden rendben lesz. Tehát azt kell
mondani, hogy menjél. Tehát azt kell
mondani, hogy menjél el a kontrollra,
mert ez sokkal fontosabb, mint azt
mondani, hogy hát minden rendben, mer
legszívesebben nem mennél és így
bátorítás az nekem legalábbis vannak
ilyen érzésem. Nehéz, nehéz, hogy
rávenni magunkat, és hogy tudjuk, hogy
kötelezően kell menni, és hogy hiába
mondják azt, hogy minden rendben lesz,
mert hogy első alkalommal is úgy mentem
oda, hogy minden rendben lesz, és nem
volt rendben. Tehát hogy a
megtapasztalás, tehát hogy annak
ellenére, hogy Isten velem van, hogy én
már egyszer végigcsináltam. Tehát
ugyanúgy félek én ettől a szenvedéstől,
amit végigcsináltam. A minden rendben
lesz, mert mintogyha implicitbe bele
lenne szőve az, hogy alaptalan a
félelmed, és te közben érzed azt, hogy
hát hogy lenne alaptalan. Legutóbb is
volt alapja. Igen. Igen. Tehát néha néha
ez a ez a minden rendát tényleg
elcsépelt,
merthogy ez valóban úgy jön le, tehát
úgy is érezheti a beteg, vagy aki készül
kontrollra a gyógyult beteg, hogy hogy
őt nem vesszik komolyan.
Tehát amennyiben valaki ezt így
odadobja, hogy jaj, hát az már nem
számít, minden rendben lesz. Nem veszi
komolyan a másik embernek az érzéseit,
hogy hogy bizony az ott van benne a
pakliba, hogy minden egyes alkalommal,
amikor odamegyek, akkor mondhatnak
bármit. És tényleg a kolléganőimnek
elmeséltem ezt, hogy azt figyeltem meg
magamon az elmúlt években, ahogy
kontrollokra jártunk, hogy nem nem
aggódom, tehát nem görcsölök én rá erre
a gondolatra, hogy jaj, megyünk s mit
fognak mondani. Tehát ez tényleg hál
istennek nagyon jól tudom
kezelni. Csak amit megfigyeltem, hogy
csak addig a napig tart az életem.
Tehát ha tudok egy pontos dátumot, most
konkrétan valamelyik évben augusztus
26-án volt a pontos időpontom
Kolozsvárra, és ekkor jöttem rá, hogy
milyen érdekes, hogy ez hogy tehát ekkor
ismertem én ezt fel, mert addig nem tűnt
fel, de mivel nyár volt és vakáció, és
ugye elég gyakran futottunk bele ebbe,
hogy jaj anya, csinálnunk-e ezt, vagy
megyünk-e oda, egyszer csak rájöttem,
hogy nem tudok tervezni. Tehát megálltak
a gondolataim ott, hogy augusztus
26-a, és az összes további életem attól
függ, hogy nekem Koloszváron mit fognak
mondani augusztus 26-án, akkor neked az
az új év, mert ha azt mondják, tehát ez
most csak egy random dátum, de hogyha
most nekem felmegyek és azt mondják,
hogy nem okés a dolog, akkor nekem 180
fokos fordulat, és továbbra Én hiába
terveztem bármit is, mert az életem
teljesen másról fog szólni. Ha azt
mondják, hogy rendben van, akkor
hazajövök és csináljuk tovább a
hétköznapi életünket. Lehet tervezni.
Igen. Tehát, hogy különben is ez, hogy
egy-egy lépésbe tervezek. Tehát, hogy
nem olyan, mint azelőtt, hogy most akkor
ilyen hosszútávon, hogy majd aztán jövő
nyáron
elmegyünk, vagy nem? Most tehát, hogy
hogy ennyi és hogy az Úr, hogy hogyha
akarja és tehát, hogy nem nem tartok már
mindent
ilyen ennyire kézbe, és hogy nem tudom
megengedni magamnak, hogy olyan nagyon
előre tervezgessek.
Itt amúgy rengeteg kérdésem lenne tovább
ezzel kapcsolatban is, de egy valami
érdekel, egy kicsit visszamennék még,
hogy beszéltünk az elejéről és mondjuk
úgy a mostani állapotról, de mi történik
közte? Tehát például engem nagyon
érdekelne, mi történik akkor, amikor
például elhull a hajatok, hogy hogyan
élitek ezt meg. És ezt az annak kapcsán
is kérdezem, hogy hogy az életfonál az
egy nagyon szimpatikus kezdeményezés
volt, amit amit Pfy King a barátom
szervezett meg. És már régóta hallottam
tőle, évek óta már beszélgetünk erről,
hogy a szívében ott van egy ilyen, még ő
se tudta pontosan, de valahol szerette
volna a stílustanácsadást ötvözni egy
egy bizonyos szolgálattal.
És hogy ennek az életfonálnak ez ez is
volt a víziója, hogy azoknak a daganatos
betegeknek, akik akiknek az önbecsülése
ilyenkor a padlón van, akik azt
gondolják, hogy ők nem szépek, hogy ezt
a paradigmaváltást megejteni, hogy az
ember nem attól szép, mert és bármit
mondunk utána, az
valójában ne nehéz megfogalmazni, mit is
jelent a szépség, hogy honnan is ered ez
a szépség. Egy kicsit beszélgetnék
erről, hogy mi mivel tudom, ti is részt
vettetek ezen az eseményen, sőt nem is
akárhogyan vettetek részt, mint mint
túlélők, akik tudtátok már bátorítani a
többieket, tudtatok már saját
tapasztalat alapján mesélni pár dolgot.
Kicsit mesélnétek erről, hogy ti hogyan
éltétek meg ezt az időszakot női
szempontból? Hát ez nem nagyon nagyon
nem egyszerű időszak. Tehát hogyha most
azt vesszük, hogy akkor amikor rendben
vagyunk, tehát egy nő tökéletesen
rendben van a hajam, sminkem, formám, és
nem elégedett, tehát odaáll a tükörrel,
és azt mondja, hogy nem vagyok elég
szép, elég csínos. Tehát akkor most
képzeljük el azt a nőt, akit
lecsupaszítanak.
Tehát teljesen lecsupaszodik a nő. Tehát
minden, ami a nőiének a szimbóluma,
mondjam így, vagy egy
kicsimbóluma. Tehát ugye itt nem csak a
hajukat vesztik el a nők, hanem időnként
a mellüket
is,
amit nem lehet nem lehet odamenni. Tehát
az, hogy odamegy valaki és ezt a
mondatot elmondani, hogy jaj, nem számít
az, csak a hajad majd visszanő, hát
ilyet nem szabad mondani. Tehát nem kell
mondani, hát azt mi is tudjuk, hogy
vissza fog nőni, csak hogy attól még
kopaszok vagyunk. Tehát itt megállni
ezen az állapoton és ezen a formán,
ez szerintem az egyik nagyon-nagyon
nehéz
folyamata, tehát a nem, tehát itt most
nem kezelés, mert hogyhogy érzem magam,
hanem hogy tényleg minőségemben, tehát
női
minőségemben meg kell meg kell álljak.
Tehát én erre emlékszem,
amikor amikor beszürkült a bőröm, tehát
a kemoterápiától. Tehát nem volt elég
az, hogy nem volt hajam, nem volt
szemöldököm, szempillám, hanem egy
reggel úgy ébredtem fel, hogy ilyen
ezüstszke a bőröm, és teljesen. Tehát
még ilyen tényleg olyan volt, hogy hát
mondom, egy holnap reggel, mint egy
acélember úgy kelek fel, merthogy és itt
volt a azt hiszem az a pont, amikor
amikor levetköztem, hogy nézzem meg,
hogy az egész testemen ugyanolyan
szürke-e a bőröm.
Hát meg nehéz megállni, tehát
nagyon-nagyon nehéz megállni és
szembenézni és kimondani,
hogy hogy hát ez
csúnya és
nagyon sokat segít. Tehát egy ilyen
projekt, amit nyújt az életfonál, hogy
tényleg ebben a minőségben, tehát olyan
és főleg az, hogy erre szakképzett
szakembereket, tehát hogy azokat a
szakembereket képezték is ebbe az
irányba, hogy az a nő, aki odamegy a
szürke bőrével, a kopasz fejével, azt ő
tudja kezelni, mert ha nem tanítják s
nem mondják el neki, akkor ő nincs,
ahonnan tudja, hogy mit kell kezdjen
azzal. hogy odamegyek és azt mondom,
hogy le kell tolni kopaszra a fejemet,
vagy kérek egy olyan sminket, ami
passzol a a az acélszürke
bőrömhöz. És itt ismét
most a tehát
betegnőknek is, vagy betegnőként is,
hogy ami nekem például segített, hogy
megmertem állni, tehát hogy én ezzel
szembe mertem nézni. Tehát emlékszem,
amikor én feltettem a kérdést, tehát azt
a kérdést ott úgy, hogy ha most ez nem
változna meg, de nagyon jó érzés volt
tudni, hogy ez egy átmeneti, tehát
tényleg meg fog
változni, de ha nem változna meg, tehát
ha én így maradnék ezzel a külsővel, el
tudnám-e fogadni magamat?
És
itt azt hiszem, hogy ismét jön a jó
Isten, és ad egy vadonatúj szemüveget a
vadonatúj külsőhöz.
De hogy ezt ezt ez nagyon fontos, hogy
tisztázzuk. Az előbb azt mondtad,
hogy belenéztél a tükörbe és azt
mondtad, hogy ez csúf. Persze. Tehát és
akkor jön a vadonat új szemüveg, és azt
tudod mondani, jön vad Igen. Tehát jön a
vadonat új szemüveg, amin keresztül
képessé válok meglátni azt, hogy tehát
hogy változik, tehát hogy átmeneti és
tudom azt, hogy el tudok indulni a szép
irányába. Ühüm. Tehát elindítod, el kell
indítsd a lelkedet abba a szép irányba.
De hogy nagyon fontos, nem? Tehát
nagyon-nagyon f a szépnek látás az
valahol ott van szerintem az
elfogadásnál. Nekem ott volt. Tehát én
azzal, hogy meg tudtam állni, és azt
mondtam, hogyha nem lenne változás,
akkor is el kéne én ezt a testet
fogadjam, mert él és mozog. Tehát nem
halt meg. Tehát ez az enyém. De él.
Akkor az akkor már ebben már benne volt
az a szépség, hogy tehát azt veszem
szemügyre, és akkor azt mondom, hogy
hát tehát vegyük
aprólékosan, benne van a szépség. Tehát
sokkal szebb az, ami tehát ez ebből
valami nagyon szép tud lenni.
Kinga, te hogy élted ezt meg? Nekem
nagyon nehéz volt. Nekem a igazából
a amikor a hajamat levágták, akkor az az
volt a
legmélyebb legmélyebb pontja a
betegségemnek. Én gyerekként nem voltam
otthon hercegnő, nem voltam apukámnak a
hercegnője. Nem volt ilyen visszajelzés
gyerekkoromban se, tehát hogy szép
vagyok, vagy ilyen. Mindig azt
emlegették, hogy a hajam. Tehát, hogy a
hajam az az nagyon szép, és én ezzel
ezzel nőttem föl,
hogy hogy a hajam az szép. És
akkor a gyerekem, ahogy megszületett,
ő ilyen hajazós gyerek volt, tehát hogy
fiú létére, de sosem volt olyan, hogy
meghúzza a hajam, vagy megtépjen
ilyesmi, hanem mikor sírt, vagy valami
valami szomorúsága volt, akkor jött
hajazni. És akkor az olyan volt, hogy a
kis tenyerével így a fürtjeimet,
mintának, így a fürtjeimet ez így
meg simogatta,
megemelgette, tehát hogy neki is nagy
kötődése volt a hajamhoz. És
mikor tudtam, hogy az első kezelés után
el fog hullni a hajam, akkor úgy is
voltunk egyezve, hogy ketten fogunk
elmenni és levágatom a hajam.
De hála a drága jó Istennek, hogy nem
sikerült ez így, mertogy jött egy olyan
gondolat egyik délelőtt, hogy éreztem,
hogy meg van halva a
hajam. Az különben az egy nagyon
érdekes, erős érzés, és hogy ez nem
fogja kibírni, hogy megvárjam a fiamat,
és hogy inkább azelőtt én elmegyek és
levágatom. És nagyon jó volt, hogy nem
volt ott, mert egy óriási óriási erős
gyász volt akkor bennem.
Tehát amíg levágták a hajamat, akkor
tudatosult bennem, hogy igenis most ez
egy ez egy ez egy kemény dolog, amit
csinálok.
Úgyhogy teljesen tehát úgy éreztem, hogy
minden
szépségemtől
megfosztottak, teljesen
lecsupaszítottak, és hogy hogy ezt így
kell csinálni.
Az
életfonál. Erről egy kicsit még nem
bánnám, ha mesélnétek, hogy aki ebben
van benne, ebbe az érzésbe, ebbe a
gyázba, amit most te leírtál, ebbe a
kétjbe, meg ilyenkor az üres szavak,
amikor ilyen felületesen jön valaki,
hogy úgy is szép vagy, mert a szépség az
belülről fakad, és nem számít, hogy
van-e hajad. Nem számít, nem a ruha
teszi az embert. El tudom képzelni,
ilyenkor így a bicska kinyílik a
zsebedbe, és azt mondod, hogy takarodj
innen, mer Igen. Én nekem ilyenkor
mindig, hogy mikor mondják, hogy tudom,
hogy nem a ruha teszi az embert, hogy
van mondta volt ugye már nagyon rég,
hogy tudom mi a tejben a lé tudom ruhat
eszi az ember. Tehát, hogy igenis
számít, számít a külső, mert hogyha nem
lenne nekem elholva a hajam, akkor úgy
végig tudnék menni az utcán, hogy hogy
nem fordítja el senki se a fejét. Hogyha
meglenne a hajam, akkor nem történne az
meg, hogy csak minden második vagy
ötödik vagy 10 ismerősöm köszön vissza,
mert én nem ismer meg. Na, ez egy olyan
téma, ami érdekel, hogy ez tényleg így
ez történt veletek, hogy a Igen. Tehát,
hogy egy olyan egy olyan
nő, aki egy hosszú, tömött, sűrű,
göndörhajjal éli az életét, úgy volt
iskolás és munkatárs, és és hogy nem
tehát, hogy hogy ijesztő volt, hogy
elmentem a kirakat előtt, és hogy
odakaptam a fejem, hogy ki az, aki aki
ott visszatükröződik a kiragadva. Tehát
saját magamat nem ismertem föl. Üm, és
hogy tényleg, hogy azt elfogadni, hogy
én akár így is lehetek, ez ez ahogy
szép, az nehéz. Ö viszont, hogy nagyon
sokat számít azért, hogy a
a kinti emberek, hogy mit mit sugalnak
nekem, mert nekem például az volt egy
nagyon nagy segítség, hogy hogy mi
Annával el szoktuk azt nevetgélni, hogy
mikor mi kopaszok voltunk. Mi nagyon
keveset használtunk kendőt, és nem
használtunk parókát sem, merthogy mi
elhittük, hogy nekünk ki van nőve a
hajunk, de közben nem volt még kinőve,
mertogy hogy volt mellettünk egy-egy
olyan ember, aki aki elhitette velünk,
hogy
kezdte kezdtük elhinni, hogy hogy ez a
kissi hajunk is, hogy milyen szép
Üüm, hogy hogy tehát hogy tényleg mikor
reálisan az embernek nem volt haja, de
mégis hogy azt hitt tehát én le első
percben én mikor levettem a kendőt
az az ember előtt, aki aki azelőtt is
elmondta, mert hogy nekem ez ez is, hogy
nagy humora van az Istennek tényleg.
Mertogy én, akivel megismerkedtem a
mostani párom,
ő azért tűntem föl neki, mertogy
gyönyörű szép hajam van. És mire
odakerültünk, hogy megismerjük egymást,
én kopasz voltam.
És hogy ez az ember, aki azért akart
megismerkedni velem, merthogy gyönyörű
szép hajam van, és
megengedte, hogy megmutassam magam úgy,
hogy kopasz vagyok, és elfogadott
olyannak, hogy kopasz vagyok. Ez egy
akkora segítség volt és egy akkora
áldás, és hogy ott vettem előtte le
először a
kendőt, mert hogy azt mondtam, hogy
hogyha hát hogyha így mondja, akkor
akkor az biztos így van. Tehát, hogy
elhittem, el akartam én inni, el akartam
inni, hogy hogy
igenis, hogy így is. Tehát igen, hogyha
a legne legmélyebb pillanatodban lát és
úgy is azt mondja, akkor csak igaz
lehet. Igen. Igen. Tehát, hogy el akarja
hinni, és az ember akar kapaszkodókat
keresni, és hogy hogy ez az életfonal is
egy kapaszkodó,
tehát hogy az olyan nagyon jó, hogy
tényleg ennyi ember megszólítódott, és
annyian összegyűltünk, merthogy ez egy
tényleg olyan fonal, ami meg tud
tartani, ami fönn tud, mertogy most ez
az időszaka van az embernek, és hogy mi
ezt azért már tudjuk, hogy milyen. hogy
hogy ez a ez az érzékenyítés, ez a ez a
sebünknek a felvállalása, mennyivel
könnyebb egy olyan helyen felvállalni az
én sebemet, ahol már ugyanilyen sebzett
emberek vannak, merthogy az a fonál
minket meg tud tartani, mert nehezebb
fölvállalni, hogy végigmenjek a elmenjek
egyet vásárolni a mit tudom melyik
üzletbe, mert mert az volt nehezebb. De
itt mennyivel könnyebb ez? Az
életfonaltáborban például
figyeltem, hogy érkeztek a hölgyek a
kiskapba,
kiskendővel. Olyan
szépek. És pár órával később, mikor
körülnéztünk, akkor azt láttuk, hogy
lekerültek a kalapok, lekerültek a kis
kendők, és mégis mindenki felszabadultan
beszélgetett,
mosolygott, vidám volt, nem számított.
Tehát annyira fontos a közösség, tehát
hogy ugyanabban a köz és meg tud
erősödni, tehát ő abba a közösségbe,
hogyha meg tudja élni azt az érzést,
hogy hogy szép vagyok, és tényleg szépek
azok a nők,
akkor kint is könnyít a helyzeten. Tehát
attól vannak olyan pillanatok, amikor az
ember otthon készül az üzletbe,
felöltözik, semmi baja nincs magával, ki
kell menni, és amikor így véletlenül
belepillantasz a tükörbe, akkor nem
tudsz kimenni. Tehát volt ilyen nem
egyszer, hanem nagyon sokszor, hogy
belepillantok, s azt mondtam, hogy na
most nem, tehát ma nem az a nap van,
hogy hogy ki tudjak menni, mert mert ma
nem jó, nem megy a dolog, tehát nem
tudom elviselni azt, hogy megbámulnak az
emberek. Y a közösségről beszélve talán
zárásként egy kicsit meséljetek erről a
jó reménység közösségről is. Tudom, hogy
a szíveteken van kíváncsi, én nem nem
hallottam előtte róla, és talán ez egy
jó adás. Pont arról, hogy egy kicsit
beszéljünk róla, hogy mi is ez? Igen, ez
nekem nekem személyesen óriási segítség
volt. Tehát én nem is tudom, hogy hogy
tudtam volna a jó reménységcsoport
nélkül végigcsinálni. Nagyon nagyon
sokat számít ugye, hogy ez ezt a
sebzettségünket hogy felvállalni és hogy
nyíltan beszélgetni dolgokról. Tehát,
hogy hogy az én cipőm, hogy a te cipőd,
hogy te most milyen szakaszában vagy,
mertogy itt itt nem egyforma szakaszában
vagyunk az élet, tehát hogy ennek a
betegségnek van, aki gyógyult. Sőt, az
is milyen sokat számít, hogy olyanok is
vannak, akik már tizen éve t éve, hogy
gyógyultak és odajárnak. És van olyan,
aki
most van a kemá kez
kis csoport két csoport van.
Igen. Ilyesmi. De hogy ahhoz képest,
hogy milyen nagyon sokan vagyunk, ilyen
betegek nagyon kevesen. Ijesztően
kevesen vannak. Tehát, hogy még mindig
tudjuk, hogy vannak olyan olyan hölgyek,
olyan férfiak, akik nem mernek kimenni
az útra, és nem, tehát, hogy még mindig
szégyenként élik meg a betegségüket.
Hogy bűnösök, és hogy Isten verése ez,
hogy én azt szoktam mondani, hogyan mint
a tetvesség a a régi időszakban, hogy
mindenki otthon próbálja megoldani ezt a
dolgot. Tehát, hogy nemzik, de nem
beszél, de hogy hogy pedig, hogy ez ez
egy egy nagyon jó közösség, ahol ahol
egymásnak tanácsot tudunk mondani, mert
ott megengedjük magunknak, hogy tanácsot
adjunk egymásnak, mert lehet ami tehát,
hogy elmondom, hogy nekem ez segített,
ha gondolod, próbáld meg. vagy tudom
azt, hogy én kemoterápia idő alatt a
szájamat öblögettem szóda bikarbonás
vízzel, és lehet, hogy neki a kórházban
senki se fogja elmondani, és neki
nincsen, aki elmondja, de én tudom azt,
hogy ez tényleg jó, és ebbe kapaszkodj
bele, mert óriási nagy segítség egy
egyszerű szóda bikarbó más visz, vagy
az, hogy most menjél el a hivatalra,
mert fogsz kapni egy ilyen kis cetlit,
amivel tudsz parkolni olyan helyen is,
ahol más helyen, mert Mert hogy hol egy
laboreredmény, hogy gyógyszertár elkel
jussál, és hogy nem ez tényleg praktikus
segítségek, amin praktikus segítségek,
és azon kívül, hogy hogy nem arról szól,
tehát hogy egy vidámközösség, ahol de
ahol akár a gyásznak is a helye van, és
a sírásnak is helye van, de nem egymásra
borulva bömbölünk és síratjuk magunkat,
hanem élni akarunk.
És és ami nagyon jó, hogy itt
szakemberek segítik a csoportot, tehát
hogy hogy nem tartunk ott még sajnos itt
Romániában, hogy legyen
onkópszichológusunk nekünk, vagy
pszichológusunk, nem tudjuk megengedni,
mert sokszor anyagi problémák is vannak
a betegséggel együtt. Igen. És itt van
egy egy szak szakember, aki aki segít a
a megélésbe, a túlélésbe, az átlépésbe,
a fejlődésbe.
Zárásként három. Mit tanácsolnátok, ha
kérdésem lesz, vagy mit tanácsolnátok a
következő személyeknek? Tehát az első
kérdés, mit tanácsolnátok annak a
személynek, aki gyanítja, hogy van
valami, de nem fél elmenni. Fél elmenni,
nehogy kiderüljön, hogy hogy rákos, hogy
el kell menni, tehát hogy merjen
elmenni, merjen segítséget kérni olyat,
aki támogatja őt abba, hogy elmerjen
menni, merthogy egyáltalán nem mindegy,
hogy a betegségnek melyik stádiumában
derül ki a betegség. Tehát a daganatos
betegségek jó részénél most már hál
istennek akkor is kezelhető a daganat,
hogyha a kezelés
drasztikus, de hogyha nagyon
előrehaladott stádiumban van, akkor
jelentősen megromlik a a kezeléseknek a
gyógyulásnak a helyzete. Tehát ha
gyanítja, akkor muszáj szembenézni azzal
a félelemmel, és muszáj elmenni, hogy jó
esetben azt mondják, hogy nincs ok
aggodalomra, és az milyen jó érzés.
Tehát ezt is kell tudni, hogy utána hogy
megnyugszom. Tehát többet nem élek
együtt azzal a
félelemmel. De ha azt mondják, hogy nem
nincs rendbe, akkor időben vagyunk arra,
hogy meg tudjuk fogni a betegséget.
És akkor a következő kérdés, hogy mit
tanácsolnátok annak a személynek, aki a
diagnózist a kezébe kapja, és most
tudja, tehát írja rajta, hogy rákja van,
megtudja. Ez az a pillanat, amikor a
levegő elfogy, amikor Mit tanácsolnátok
ennek a szemének? Ez nehéz, ez ez
szerintem nehezebb. Én is az, hogy
mindenképpen menni kell, és sőt a a
szűrővizsgálatokat is nagyon javasolom.
Azt azt mindenképpen kéne mindenképpen
kéne csinálni.
Hát, hogy hát ez egy nagyon nehéz, tehát
annak nehéz tanácsot adni, merthogy
mindenki tényleg egyéni és sajátos módon
tudja megélni azt, hogy de azt hiszem,
hogy
elsősorban azt,
hogy nincs
egyedül, tehát ott van a jó
reménységcsoport, ott vannak mindig, ott
van egy egy kéz, ami ami után ki lehet
nyúlni, hogy hogy bele merjen
kapaszkodni. És azt is,
hogy hogy nem tudom mit. Hogy kérni kell
segítséget, tehát nem kell félni a
segítségkéréstől. Merthogy vannak jó
emberek, vannak segítők ezek csak, hogy
azt iszkre kell venni. De előbb kell
kérjek, előbb kell kérjek, hogy hogy
tudjak kapni.
De ez aki kér, az kap, aki kopogtat ajó.
Igen, igen, de hogy meg kell tanuljunk,
mert hogy ez a kérés is, ez is, tehát
hogy amit a médiasal, hogy jól kell
lenni, nem kell kérni, mindenem megvan,
ezt mutatjuk kifele, de hogy nem
igazából az emberi értékek azért
megvannak és és kell, és hogy tényleg
ott vannak. Tehát az, aki már
végigcsinálta a folyamatot, az szinte
kivétel nélkül mindenki teljesen nyitott
arra, hogy segítsen, hogy segítsen.
Tehát ez ott fogalmazódik meg abban a
pillanatban, ahogy az ember a
legeslegelső segítségét megkapja
valahonnan, vagy nem kapja, hogy tehát
ha én ezt túlélem, akkor én mindenkinek
fogok segíteni, és olyan
gyakorlat ismét a segítség, hogy nem
kell nagyban gondolkodni. Tehát akkor
sem, amikor valakiről kiderül, tegyük
fel hozzátartozó vagy ismerősként, és
jön az érzés, hogy jaj, kellene
segítsek, de hát hogy tegyem? Hát inkább
visszahúzódok, mertogy olyan gyakorlati
segítségek, az apró, tehát annyira
egyszerű segíteni, hogy néha azért nem
látjuk, mert mert annyira egyszerű.
Tehát emlékszem, hogy a legesleelső utam
Kolozsvárra. Tehát előtte engem
felhívott egy lány, aki nem tényleg nem
tudom, hogy honnan tudta meg. Nem is nem
volt ismerősöm. Később együtt jártunk
egyébként kemoterápiás kezelésekre. Ő
előttem volt egy pár
körrel, és elmondta, hogy ha felmegyek
Kolozsvárral, bemegyek a zöld épületbe,
elmegyek, sorszámot veszek, a melyik
ablakhoz? Hányadik emeletre? Ott a
folyosón.
Mikor felmentem Kolozsvánra, és ezt
gyakorlatilag egy vadidegen
intézménybe találod magad, tényleg azt
se tudod, de tudtam. Tehát tudtam, mert
elmondták. Én akkor fogalmaztam meg
legelőször, hogyha túlélek, akkor én
mindenkinek segítek. Tehát már az érzés
megjelenik egyébként, hogy segíteni
akarsz azért, mert megtapasztaltad a
segítséget, hogy mekkora segítségek
tudnak lenni, hogy ismételten
kihangsúlyozzom minden új esetnek, hogy
egy pillanatig se gondolkozzanak azon,
hogy mernek-e segítséget kérni, vagy
hogy nem szabad, nem illik, nem kell ezt
egyedül csinálni. álni. Tehát csoport is
van. Mindenkinek az ismerős körében van
valaki, aki már túl van rajta. Lehet
tényleg olyan segítségek, a segítségek,
amit nem is ítélünk meg elsőre, úgyhogy
ez segítség lehet. Gyakorlatilag itt a
harmadik kérdésemre is válaszoltál, mert
pont ezt akartam kérdezni, hogy mit
tanácsolnátok annak a személynek, aki
otthon van, szégyeli magát, egyedül
próbálja megoldani? Tehát erről
beszéltetek most.
Nem kell egyedül megoldani. Nem kell
egyedül megoldani. Kell kérni, meg kell
tanulni, kérni. És a másik nekem például
ami nagyon
nagy nehézség volt, hogy megtanuljam a
segítséget
elfogadni, merthogy hogy tényleg, hogy
az anyagi helyzet is ilyenkor nagyon
meginog. Tehát, hogy igazából
lecsupaszod az Igen. És hogy nekem
mekkora segítség volt az, hogy
felajánlották, hogy hogy elhoznak és
visszavisznek Kolozsvára. És így akor
hét megt az oldódva, hogy hétvégudam
látni a gyermekem, hazudtam jönni, hanem
meg se tudtam volna oldani, mertogy nem
voltunk olyan állapotban, vagy nincsen
úgy az ember olyan állapotban, hogy
beüljön az autóba és elvezessen. Igen.
Tehát, hogy ez ilen ilyen igen, de hogy
el is fogadni, tehát hogy egyedül álló
anyaként azért ez egy óriási dolog volt,
hogy hogy elfogadni a segítség
kollégáim, akik tudták, tehát ők tudták
azt, hogy nekem ezzel nagyon nagy
problémáim voltak, hogy nem is azért nem
kérek segítséget, mert nehéz elfogadni.
Tehát nekem nem jut eszembe, tehát az
egyedülálló anyaságnak a az egyik
hozadéka ez, hogy annyira egyedül oldod
meg a problémáidat, hogy elfelejted,
hogy kérhetnél
segítséget. És a kollégáim ezt nem is
várták meg, hogy segítséget kérni, de
hogy a legeslegnagyobb segítség ez volt,
hogy felhívtak és elmondták, hogy mikor
ki visz fel Kolozsvárra.
Még sok kérdésem lenne, de azt hiszem,
hogy a vég végére érkeztünk ennek a
beszélgetésnek. Az az igazság el is
váradtam. Ez egy érzelmileg intenzív al
valami volt nekem, és és nagyon hálás
vagyok, hogy hogy eljöttetek és
beszélhettünk ezekről a tabú témákról,
amik nem is tudom, nem kéne tabuk
legyenek, de nem kéne, de én személyesen
most például azt tanultam, hogy hogy a
nem túl közeli ismerősökkel
hogyan hogyan kezeljem ezt le. ö hogy
hogy mi az én feladatom ilyenkor.
Köszönöm mindenesetre, hogy itt voltatok
Kinga és Anna. Szerintem egy szuper
beszélgetés volt és és gyanítom, hogy a
nézőknek is ez egy szuper beszélgetés
volt. Igazából had szem közb
beszélgettünk, de de gyanítom, hogy sok
visszajelzést fogtok kapni erről
és és sok áldást nektek. Köszönjük
szépen. Viszont ha tetszett ez a műsor,
akkor iratkozz fel kérlek a
csatornánkra, ezzel tudsz támogatni
minket. Köszönjük a Week kávé
közösségnek a jó kávéért, az ötcös
udvarnak a helyért, valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért.
Nélkületek nem jöhetett volna ez létre.